Getting bigger,
but the video part is getting to a
larger percentage.
Three,
two,
one.
Gentlemen,
we're live.
Here we go.
Jordan Peterson,
Bret Weinstein.
How are you guys doing?
Very well.
He's coming in to be here.
I'm excited to have you in.
Hey,
should,
shouldn't be for you.
Your spiffy.
You make us look a very schlubby.
When are you doing?
What can I say,
man?
You know,
I only brought a limited number of
clothes.
Well,
good move.
You look great.
And I'm good to see you as both of you.
And uh,
so,
uh,
whose idea was it to do this?
First of all?
So just to,
I think it was,
I think it was Brett's.
Yeah,
I saw it.
A tweet of Jordan's about a,
or maybe it wasn't a tree.
I did see a youtube clip that somebody
tweeted,
I don't know if it was you,
your perspective on,
um,
on Hitler.
And uh,
your argument was that he was actually
even far worse than his reputation would
lead us to believe.
And it's funny at,
it hearkens back to my first
evolutionary project as an
undergraduate.
I was working with Bob Trevor's,
who's one of the leading evolutionary
minds of the 20th century.
He was,
I was lucky enough to have him as an
undergraduate advisor.
Pull this sucker right up to your face
because you're going to turn sideways
because we're looking at each other.
Is that next to each other?
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
anyway,
I did a,
a,
a project with Bob on analyzing the
Holocaust from an evolutionary
perspective.
I wanted to test the question about
whether,
you know,
at the time it was,
it was commonplace for people to say
that Hitler was crazy and there was
something that bothered me about that
analysis.
I think there's something actually
dangerous that we dismiss somebody like
Hitler as crazy before we understand
actually what they're up to you.
So when I saw your,
your video clip,
I thought it would be worth having a
discussion so that we could figure out
what perspective.
Make Sense.
That sounds like an awesome topic.
But before we get to that,
I would really like to know what's going
on with you because you're at the center
of this crazy controversy of evergreen
state college.
You essentially left the area,
your,
uh,
suing the college now.
So where do you stand now?
We have not yet filed suit and in fact I
can talk
about what took place inside the
negotiation,
but we had our first sit down with the
college yesterday and,
uh,
this was,
an attempt to,
to avert a suit,
but I will say from where I sit,
as hard as this is to believe,
it appears that the college has learned
nothing from this episode and that it is
doubling down on the same foolish sets
of beliefs and assumptions that got into
trouble in the first place.
So that,
that is not a hopeful situation.
No.
And for anybody that's not aware of what
this whole story's about,
you would either have to go back to
Brett's podcast that we did a few months
back,
or please just google evergreen state
university and Google Brett and you will
be blown away by the incident.
It's social
justice warrior.
Gone Amok,
the whole campus kids patrolling the
campus with baseball bats.
I mean,
the whole thing is just completely
bananas.
The president of the university,
uh,
being told by the children not to use
his hands when he speaking because it's
a microaggression.
So he puts his hands down,
the children start cheering and
laughing.
They don't realize they're being played.
The whole thing is just some crazy grand
game by the children.
And I'm calling them children.
I don't give a fuck how old they are to,
to have power over people.
I mean essentially what this is all
boiling down to and you really see it in
that moment where they tell him to put
his hands down and he does.
And they,
they laugh and cheer and think it's
amazing.
Well,
you know,
they're,
they're educated to do that to some
degree because one of the tenants of the
postmodernism that they're being spoon
fed is that there's no such.
There's nothing but power.
That's the only thing that mediates
relationships between people because
there's no real world.
Everything's a social construct and it's
a landscape of conflict between groups.
That's the postmodern world.
And the only,
the only actual means of expression is
power.
That's why the postmodernists make the
claim constantly that the patriarchy is
a corrupt institution because they look
at hierarchical organizations and
they're stratified.
Obviously there's people at the top and
people at the bottom.
The only reason that there are people at
the top is because they dominate by
power.
There's no,
there's no philosophy of authority or
competence that's all gone.
And so,
and,
and if you're cynical about that sort of
thing and you should be,
you might say that part of the reason
that the only thing that the postmodern
disbelieve in his powers,
because that helps them justify their
arbitrary use of it under any
circumstances whatsoever.
And I think that's right.
I think that's exactly what happened.
So it's not surprising that you see this
manifested in that mall,
Blake behavior of the students.
It's right in accordance with everything
they're being taught so well.
They're also being taught in this sort
of any means necessary to,
uh,
to get over the establishment.
The establishment is this horrible
institution and they could justify
pretty much anything.
Yeah.
This is what like punch a Nazi who's a
Nazi.
Everybody that doesn't agree with you.
I mean it's essentially what's,
what's being said Ad Nauseum in,
in social justice warrior circles
online.
And you see,
I've seen punching Nazis so many times.
I mean,
but when it came down to
Charlottesville,
there was very little punching Nazis.
You know,
the whole thing was like,
it's all,
it's all very insane.
We see real Nazis like those are real
Nazis,
you know,
like go fucking punch them.
Please know they thought.
We've also,
I think don't even do that by the way.
Well,
I think we've already figured out
everyone right from the right to the
left.
Everyone's figured out that wherever the
Nazis went,
that was wrong.
We've all agreed on that.
We're not going there anymore.
And so when someone pops up and says,
well,
we should go there,
it's like they're immediately
identifiable.
You can box them in and if you have any
sense like you know,
like many conservatives did in the
aftermath of Charlottesville,
they come out and say,
well,
in case it needs to be said again,
we're actually not allied with those
people.
Yeah,
well that's one of the.
That was the most disturbing thing for
many people about Donald Trump's
reaction to it,
that he didn't take a hard stance
against these white supremacists showing
up with Tiki torches,
walking to the street,
yelling antisemetic phrases or whatever.
I don't know exactly what they're
yelling.
I've read a bunch of different things,
but the whole thing was a.
It was an abomination.
I mean it was a horrific thing to watch
and you know,
Donald Trump comes out and says there
was horrible behavior on all sides.
Yeah,
well,
I thought I thought about that for a lot
because I got tangled up with that in a
strange way in Canada.
I was supposed to appear on a panel,
a panel discussing the suppression of
free speech on university campuses,
which was then promptly canceled by the
university that was going to host it in
the aftermath of Charlottesville,
partly because one of the panelists was
going to be faith Goldie who was the
journalist that was covering Charlotte's
Ville and got the footage of the,
of the car and uh,
and the damage.
But,
um,
we,
we're targeted immediately afterward
with the Nazi epithet and Ryerson cut
shut down the shutdown in the free
speech panel.
So it's coming up again in November.
Targeted as you were targeted as Nazis.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What happened was this,
this,
this person put up a facebook page and
use the swastika with a no,
you know,
like a circle with a line through it and
said,
no fascists fascists at Ryerson
essentially.
But she used the swastika and she got a
bunch of people rallied together to
pressure the university administration
into counseling the event,
which they promptly did.
And then they had a celebration party
the night of the event.
And this is,
here's something that was really
interesting.
So they got a couple,
I think a couple of hundred people out
to the celebration at Ryerson and they,
they were united under the banner of the
hammer and sickle and we're calling for
revolution.
And what was so interesting about that,
and I really mean technically that it
was interesting,
was that the mainstream media said
virtually nothing about the fact that
these,
let's call them counter protesters.
I don't know exactly how you'd turn
them,
had come out under this murderer
assemble.
And that's made me think like I can't
figure out why the swastika is an
immediate identifier of a pathological
personality and the hammer and sickle
isn't.
There's actually a reason it isn't just
arbitrary.
And I think maybe it's something like
the Nazi is the guy who knifes you in
the alley and steals your wallet and the
Communist is the white collar criminal
who,
who takes your pension and you're
actually more afraid of the first
person.
Then the second person,
because the damage they do is more
proximal and amit and emotionally
recognizable.
But that's the second guy who takes your
pension,
for example,
he's perhaps even more dangerous,
but there's a.
there's a bloodiness about the Nazi
symbol and an immediate emotional impact
that the heroin sickle just doesn't
produce and some of that's because
people are badly educated history thing
density,
but it's pure ignorance.
Just ignorance.
I think that the people that are wearing
those Che Guevara tee shirts really
understand the history of Che Guevara or
do you think he represents this sexy
South American counter protest
character?
A guy who stands up to the establishment
as we know it.
A guy who was wearing a green bar
wearing a bra hiding in the jungle,
fighting against the oppressive
dictatorship of America.
I mean that's what.
That's what they're looking at when they
see that.
Well,
the,
the fact that historical ignorance plays
a role in this.
It's absolutely certain.
And I think the Romanticization of
people like shake were various exact.
I think you nailed that exactly.
But I do think there's a deeper question
here.
It's like I was thinking in the
aftermath of Charlottesville,
many conservatives immediately divorced
themselves from the Nazis.
Ben Shapiro was a good example and and
it was very much reminiscent of William
f Buckley divorcing himself from the
John Birch society back in the 19
sixties.
The right wing seems,
it seems to be easier for the right wing
to draw a line around the Nazis and say,
no,
that's not us.
Partly because the right wingers,
conservatives are better at drawing
boundaries,
but you know,
let's say we wanted to draw a boundary
around the radical leftists.
Okay.
Point to something.
Well,
on the right you say,
well,
you are a swastika.
Yeah,
you're out of the club man on the left
while you believe.
What's the smoking pistol?
You believe in equity.
It's like,
that's,
that's a smoking pistol as far as I'm
concerned,
but it doesn't have the same emotional
punch as you wore a swastika to the
protest.
Yeah.
You believe in equity and you refuse to
define it.
That would be right,
but that's such a.
it's,
there's no emotional punch in that.
It's like,
well,
I'm not going to associate with you
because you believe in equity.
It's like,
it's too complicated.
It's right.
I do want to back us up here
because the,
I think we underrate the danger of,
and I think Nazis or red herring,
um,
there is something that actually does
threaten to reemerge and Charlottesville
is a version of it,
but I think because we have a cartoon
understanding of what that protest was
actually about and how many people are
actually involved,
we don't really see why this is a
dangerous and contentious issue and I
think the answer is an evolutionary one
that hasn't been spelled out and because
it hasn't been spelled out,
it's very hard to point to
but to keep interrupting you,
but just get this right up to your face
because it sounds good to us.
But the people listening online are
going to have a much better.
Yeah.
Just when you turn to him
the thing with you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just get it.
You always keep it a fist from your
face.
That's the best.
Uh,
sorry.
That's all right.
So explain what you mean by this.
So my point would be that what took
place in Germany in the thirties was a
particularly,
um,
particularly visible,
well documented example of a pattern
that is much more common in human
history and because this
pattern emerges as a result of certain
features of the way evolution functions
in the context of humans,
it is actually always a danger that it
will reemerge and knowing what to do
about it is a not so simple until you've
seen why it occurs and what it means.
Um,
what I,
what I've been saying in lectures I've
given on this is that tyranny is the end
game of prosperity.
And so there is a pattern in which you
will go through a period of prosperous
snus in which it appears that that thing
is defeated once and for all.
And there's no reason for people to be
going after each other in this
particular way.
And then at the point that that pattern
peters out,
it re-emerges and people don't expect
it.
It flies under a different flag or
something like that.
And so I do think that looking at the
tiny number of people who were doing
what they were doing in Charlottesville
and saying,
well,
that's.
We all agree that this is wrong,
Mrs.
The fact that actually I think trump is
doing it cynically,
but trump was riding a wave that there
are ideas which are not permissible from
the environments in which we all grew up
that are going to become permissible
again if we're not careful to recognize
that that's,
that's the nature of history.
I think it's highly probable that that's
going to occur.
I mean,
part of the reason that I landed in the
political hot water that I landed in
last year,
it was because I was increasingly aware
that this process of polarization was
going to take place and that the
continual,
in my estimation anyways,
the continual clawing of,
of new ground underneath the radical
leftist rubric,
especially in the universities is,
is starting to produce an
extraordinarily dangerous counter
position.
And that was manifest at least to some
degree in Charlottesville.
And so I think you're right.
Well,
I,
I don't want to be complacent.
Say,
well,
we know who the Nazis are and we're not
going there,
and so the problem is solved.
The problem isn't solved.
There's all sorts of weird activity in
the non-radical lefts space,
like on the other side of the radical
left,
whatever that is.
And right now what it is is not obvious.
You know,
it's,
it's the law.
All right,
that's part of it.
It's the Pakistanis.
It's this pepe thing.
It's,
it's some of it's comedy,
some of it's satire,
some of it serious.
Some of it's the inversion of identity
politics,
which is very dangerous and it's maybe
the most dangerous thing about
Charlottesville is that there's
something,
there's something extraordinarily
dangerous about having people revert to
identification with their racial
identity.
It's really not a good thing.
Well,
there's the reversion to their racial
identity.
There's basically an outbreak of
tribalism,
which explains what's going on on the
far right.
What's going on on the left is a bit of
a new twist.
What you have is a coalition of
different tribal identities that aren't
large enough to marshal of force on
their own,
and so they're united and together they
are a formidable force,
but what's going to happen is that
something that's an unstable entity at
the point that that forced gains power.
It's going to come apart as internal
dynamics rip it up so it's not actually
a a,
a,
a.
it's not capable of restraining the
version that recurs on the right.
The version that does manifest as as a
white nationalism,
that version is stable because it does
represent an actual population that has
an evolutionary basis for remaining
cohesive and I should point out there is
a danger when you hear an evolutionary
biologists talk about evolutionary
patterns,
people often infer that if an
evolutionary biologist is saying that
something is a pattern that has evolved,
that that's some kind of a defense and
it is absolutely not.
We call this the naturalistic fallacy.
So evolution is an absolutely a moral
process.
It has produced the most marvelous
features of human beings and the worst
features,
and we are in some sense obligated to
pick and choose which features to honor
and and promote and which ones to tamp
down.
Something can have something can have
evolved as a virtue in some
circumstances and still be of the type
that if magnified beyond its proper
limits,
becomes pathological.
So let me tell you something I learned
about Hitler,
which really I haven't recovered from my
shock from this.
So we'd been looking at the relationship
between political belief in personality.
Okay,
and your political belief is strongly
determined by your temperament.
So liberal left types are high in trait,
openness,
that's creativity and low in
conscientiousness,
but you can fragment conscientiousness
up into industriousness and orderliness.
And the real predictor for conservatism
is an orderliness,
not industriousness,
and you might think,
well that's no surprise,
right wingers are more orderly,
hence Hitler's call for order,
let's say,
but it's one thing to to to posit that
and another thing to measure it.
Now it's measurable and it appears that
orderliness is associated with
sensitivity to discussed.
And this is actually a really big deal.
It's a really big deal.
So there's a paper that was published in
Plos one about three years ago looking
at the relationship between the
prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarian political attitudes and
they did it country by country and then
within countries by state or province.
And the correlation between the
prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarians slash right wing
political beliefs at the local
individual level was point six.
And so I want to take this apart a
little bit.
Okay.
So the idea is that this is part of what
you might describe as the extended
behavioral immune system.
And one of the problems with the
interactions between groups of human
beings in our evolutionary past was what
exactly what happened to the native
Americans is,
you know,
they came out and shook hands with the
Spanish can keys two doors.
And then within a couple of generations,
90 percent of them were dead of smallpox
and measles and mumps.
And so it's been a truism in our past
that if you meet a group of isolated,
if you're a group of isolated humans and
you meet another group of isolated
humans and you trade pathogens,
there's a real possibility that you and
everyone you know are going to be dead
in no time flat.
And so we have a disgust mechanism that
that produces this implicit,
let's call it racial racial and ethnic
bias.
That is part and parcel of the human
cognitive landscape.
But the problem with that is that it's
rooted in a disgust mechanism that
actually serves as a protective
function.
Now,
when I was sorting this out,
I was reading Hitler's table talk and
Hitler's table talk is a very
interesting book.
It's a book,
a book of his spontaneous mealtime
utterances from 1939 to 1942.
And I went through with this new
knowledge because people think of
conservatives as like or fascist as
afraid of those who are different.
They're not afraid,
they're disgusted.
And that's not the same thing because
you burn things,
you're disgusted by.
And so it was terrifying to me to read
it because then I also thought,
oh well,
disgust,
sensitivity is associated with
orderliness and you need order in a
society in order to maintain it.
And the Germans are very orderly and
that was actually a canonical part of
their civilization and part of actually
what makes them great and powerful and
that just had to tilt a little farther
than necessary and all of a sudden
everything needed to be cleaned.
And you know,
Hitler talked about cleanliness all the
time and he actually meant that.
And so this thing that's emerging,
you know,
you talked about a biological basis,
it's evolutionary basis.
It is.
It's part of this deeply rooted disgust
system that protects us from dangerous
pathogens that can manifest itself in
and does manifest itself in the
political realm.
It's not good.
So he don't know exactly how to tease
this apart.
But I agree with your point about
there's an actual danger when
populations meet like a literal pathogen
danger and that,
that is liable to have produced a
certain instinct of a fear of,
of the other,
which doesn't have to be limited to that
one thing,
but that's enough to generate a
selective force that would cause a
certain reluctance,
um,
to meet.
But I want,
I want to point out that at least in the
West and probably universally human
beings when they go to war,
tend to dehumanize the other population
and,
you know,
so of course,
calling the other population,
sub human vermin,
whatever it is that,
that human beings do.
And my concern is that we are doing
exactly this with the Nazis are defacto
Nazis who are showing up,
uh,
on,
on our screens at this point that what
we are doing is we are comforting
ourselves by saying,
well,
that's a small outbreak of something
that makes these people subhuman,
justifies punching them or whatever.
And I'm,
you know,
I'm not squeamish about there being a
right to violence when somebody is
threatening a way of life.
So it's not that.
But my concern is that if you take the
pathogen model and you imagine that all
those folks who showed up in
Charlottesville,
that that is a contagion and it needs to
be isolated,
then you will have the sense that as
long as you do that,
it's not going to show up somewhere
else.
Whereas what's I think the,
the actual hazard is that that's
actually a latent program that has
served populations in past
circumstances.
It's indefensible,
but it has served populations and the
populations that we come from have it
therefore on reserve.
And when certain characteristics show up
in the environment,
that program can emerge.
And so my concern is that that's where
we are in history,
can't be isolated as a phenomena that's
associated with the other.
In one of the things I've done for
decades is teach my students a variant
of that which is something like.
Because we,
I try to walk them through understanding
psychological understanding of what
happened in Nazi Germany and in the more
intense situations like in places like
in Auschwitz.
And so the question might be,
well,
if you were in Germany than in the 19
thirties,
could you be a cancer concentration camp
guard?
And the gut reaction to that is no,
those people are unlike me and that's
the wrong response.
The right response is those people,
we're human and I'm also human,
and so that means that the Nazi is us.
That's what it means.
And so the.
And who the hell wants to think that no
one will think that and I have thought
that through because I thought through
for a variety of reasons what the limits
of my potential behavior are and the
limits of my potential and maybe I'm
more pathological than the average
person.
It's certainly possible,
but I understand that the limits of my
potential behavior are far beyond the
bounds of what people would normally
consider civilized.
And I think that's characteristic of
human beings in general.
Well,
I mean looking.
Oh,
go ahead.
No,
I was to say I think this is one of the
things that really highlights the
importance of having uncensored
discussions because we've already hit on
so many hot topics to the point where
you have to really clarify your position
and when you're talking about this sort
of latent program in in human beings and
the necessity for it at one point in
time,
like all these things are very tabooed
to discuss today,
and this is a giant issue because what
you guys are doing is talking about
things objective objectionably
reasonably logically and clearly,
but when you get to these sort of
hysterical subjects,
that's,
that's sort of forbidden today and
there's a giant issue with that because
when you have for bidden discussions,
you energize those topics and the topics
grow in the absence of discussion and
the absence of being picked apart and
analyzing them for what their core
components are and what were you talking
about it from an evolutionary
perspective.
This is very,
very important because these patterns
are reemerging.
We do see that and I think I need one of
us given the wrong neighborhood,
the wrong parents,
the wrong life.
We might've been one of those assholes
with the Tiki torches in Charlotte.
I mean it's.
We're human beings like you said.
I think that is absolutely to discuss
and it's also.
There's another thing going on right
now.
I've been trying to characterize the
state of the sociological and
psychological landscape that we all
inhabit right now and I think we're in a
position of radical instability and
things in the future could be way better
than they are right now,
radically and they could be way worse
than they are and small decisions are
going small.
The small decisions that people make are
going to have outsized effects while
they make them.
Like,
look at what happened with this guy in
Charlottesville.
You know,
this was.
I mean,
I know he was surrounded by a coterie of
of deplorables,
let's say,
but it was one guy who decided to do
something murderous and that shifted the
whole political landscape.
And so what I see happening right now is
that we're surrounded by these
interactions between people that are
positive feedback loops,
you know,
and a positive feedback loop occurs
when,
if you do something that it makes
whatever caused that occur even in a
greater way.
And the polarization is like that.
So I say something left blank and you
say something right,
like,
and that annoys me.
So I get more left and it annoys you and
you get more right?
And all of a sudden we're at each
other's throats and that's happening
everywhere,
right?
It's very unstable.
And what what's to be hope for is that
we can pull back from that and discuss
it.
We can say,
look,
you know,
under a circumstance ai could have been
a communist inquisitor or Nazi prison
guard.
I need to know that.
And then I need to know what were the
situations that made that likely.
And then I need to know how should I
conduct myself.
So that's less possible.
And the only way we can figure that out
is to have the kind of conversations
that we're having right now.
It's like,
and this isn't them,
I've been taken to task by some of my
friends,
for example,
for using the social justice warrior
terminology because they've said to me,
well,
you know,
you're,
you're participating in this process of
demonization and,
and polarization,
and I think,
well,
yeah,
I can understand that.
Although I'm also like radically
concerned about the fact that the
universities,
for example,
are completely taken over by radical
Marxist essentially and that they're
driving this polarization and it isn't
obvious to me how to have a discussion
about that without participating in the
process of polarization.
It's something I've been trying to
figure out for the whole last year.
You know,
and I've made.
I've been emphasizing the role of
personal responsibility instead of
ideological identification,
right?
Get it into your head that you have the
capacity for great evil and stop
targeting.
Stop assuming that that's something
that's manifesting itself only in the
people that you disagree with
politically.
Take responsibility for that and try to
put your life together.
I don't see an alternative to that,
but it's been very difficult to to to,
to avoid,
to do that and simultaneously to avoid
becoming a participant in this process
of polarization and it's a very
dangerous process.
It's what destabilized Germany in the 19
twenties and thirties,
right?
It was this ping pong back and forth
between the radical left and the radical
right.
And your point,
Brett,
that the radical right actually is more
powerful once they get organized is a
really good one because
there's no fractionation.
It's more stable.
You bet you they have all the guns.
That's another thing to think about.
Certainly in this country,
the right is much better armed and
that's very frightening thing.
That tariff terrifying thought that
we've.
We've heard this many times recently
about the trump administration about if
he's impeached,
that there will be some sort of a civil
war.
I believe Roger Stone said that like
this thought is so terrifying that we
literally cannot do anything to stop
some sort of physical confrontation with
weapons if we disagree ideologically
that it's going to happen.
Well,
first of all,
there's a lot we can do and in fact,
you know,
one of the other things about about the
evolutionary toolkit is that I believe
we have exactly the tools for navigating
this puzzle there built into us also in
addition to this latent program,
but we are now in a very dangerous
situation because for example,
if Google and other of these online
goliath start a deploying algorithms
that decide what we get to talk about
and see,
then we cannot use the very tools that
are necessary in order to escape and
avoid something like civil war,
which frankly communication and debate
analyzing all the components of this
issue completely objectively.
Exactly.
Taking the risks that are necessary with
that in some of the risks are that if we
have free and open communication,
that some percentage of that
communication is going to be
reprehensible and deplorable,
but but the but the consequences of
suppressing that are so much more
dangerous than the consequences of
allowing it that they're not in the same
universe.
Yes.
We empower those terrible ideas by
making them electronically taboo.
Yeah,
and then the point is they're going to
fester,
um,
whereas if we,
if we discuss them,
we can diffuse the ones that are
terrible.
We can spot the opportunities that we
don't know we have and we can,
uh,
we can move forward rather than descend
into civil war with frankly looks more
one more issue with,
with Google and youtube,
let's say.
And these other gigantic Internet
companies,
you know,
it isn't a matter of if they're going to
produce automated bots that do pre
perceptual censorship,
they are doing that well to explain sad
explaining.
Well he,
he,
he tweeted the other day that um,
and I knew this was in the workings
because I'd been looking at what youtube
and Google are planning with regards to
their artificial intelligence sensors.
Let's say,
you know,
they want to get to the point where the,
the apoe,
the appalling video is not even put up.
So what happened,
I hope I've got this exactly right,
but God,
uh,
was in the process.
You upload a video and then you publish
it.
And so once you upload it,
Youtube has access to it and they have
access to its content and they informed
him that it would be demonetized before
he published it.
So right here we put it up on the board.
There you go.
Youtube thinks that might pointing to
astounding.
Hypocrisy is too triggering.
There's nothing objectionable
objectionable in my clip.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
And that one was a manual review.
So I'm wrong about that,
that they.
Although how,
how in the world they decided that they
were going to manually review God's
video is also,
I mean,
how many videos are going up on Youtube?
What the hell?
Why are they manually reviewing his I
sat is not a radical,
right?
That's the thing.
I mean,
he's an evolutionary biologist and that
makes them a radical.
Now it does because he's a Bible
questioning what's happening and by
questioning what's happening,
you instantaneously get lumped into this
right wing hate groups.
And he's also making the claim that
human beings have an intrinsic nature.
And so now there's a new buzz phrase
that goes along with that.
And so that's that you're a biological
essentialist.
And See,
so if you're a radical postmodern,
neo,
Marxist,
your theory is human beings can be
anything that I want to make them into.
It's a core doctrine of the theory and
it's part of what makes it intensely
totalitarian because then human beings
are just petty for the molding and
that's part of the motivational drive
for claiming the radical constructionist
plane.
There's no biological essence,
well,
why do you make that claim?
Well,
because we want to free people from
prejudice and tyranny.
It's like,
no,
that's not why you make that claim.
You make that claim because you want to
justify your claim that there's
absolutely nothing wrong with making
over humanity in the image of your
ideology and that and that's that.
That that was a well documented
intellectual argument that that that
will through what happened in communist
Russia,
for example,
because the claim they're explicitly was
you wipe out the past.
There's no real biological identity.
You can mold the human of the future in
the image of your perfectionistic
ideology
and the Russians actually sidelined
themselves effectively with respect to
evolutionary theory that basically they
were so backward on a biological front
that as they were deploying this,
this very broken ideological toolkit,
they were wrecking their ability to
think about about how biology works.
And so what you're pointing to about
evolutionary biologist,
it's not just that we question the
content of evolutionary biology is
absolutely the opposite of politically
correct.
Yes,
exactly.
Because nobody tells the Biota what's
right and what's wrong.
The biota does what it does and those of
us who look at it and attempt to
understand what those patterns are,
can't help but be deeply politically
incorrect almost all the time.
And so the idea that the truth of
biology is actually going to become an
inexpressible.
And we're going to move ahead where
you're just gonna we're gonna.
We're gonna sideline it so that we can
move ahead with this ideological stuff.
I mean,
that is cutting off your nose spite.
Biology is racist and sexist.
You.
Well,
if I might,
um,
biology and we're going to have to go
back here in order to collect a tool,
but a biology does create entities that
have the potential for racism in them.
In our genomes,
we carry the potential for racism for
Darwinian reasons.
Sexism is a little different,
right?
It is.
So I'm about to become very politically
incorrect.
Oh yeah.
I know.
Oh,
uh,
it is not possible for male genes to
gang up on female genes because all of
our genes spend half their time in male
bodies and half their time in female
bodies,
which does not mean that civilization is
fair with respect to sex and gender,
but it does mean that there's no
biological basis for the evolution of a
patriarchal forced that subordinates
women because whatever the patriarchy
does,
those who are part of the Patriarchy
become female in the next iteration and
they suffer the consequences of it.
This is not the case with race.
Unfortunately.
This is not a good thing,
but it is a true thing in a Darwinian
sense.
One population can gang up on another
population and it has happened again and
again.
It explains all of the worst chapters in
human history and so in some sense what
I'm getting at is that you want to
understand that process and once you
understand what your genes are actually
up to and you understand that your
genes,
their objectives in the universe are not
defensible,
which are genes want cannot be defended
in,
in rational terms.
Then we become free to do something else
to recognize that our genes are up to
things that we don't have any reason to
honor and we can.
We can basically take them out of the
control position.
But if we imagine that what our genes
are up to must be all right and
therefore it can't include anything like
racism.
Then we're just stuck.
Then we don't have the tools to,
to diffuse racism.
So one of the things that happened when
I made my video,
so a year ago complaining about
[inaudible] in Canada and that was the
one that instantiated transgender
rights.
One of the things I was pointing to my,
like my comments had nothing to do with
transgender rights,
but one of the things I was pointing to
that was that Canada had built into the
law a social constructionist version of
human identity and that's actually the
case.
So for example,
now in Canada,
it here's the proposition which now has
the force of law.
There is no causal connection between
biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual proclivity.
Technically it's illegal to make a claim
that those things are causally linked
and the causal link claim is a
biological claim and not only is it a
biological claim,
it's a factual claim.
Those four levels are so tightly linked
causally that there's hardly any
exceptions.
There are exceptions,
so because every,
almost
everyone whose biological sex is male
considers themselves male,
manifests themselves as male and is
heterosexual,
so they're late and the reason they're
linked as well.
There's biological and cultural reasons,
but it's now in Canada.
The proposition that they're independent
is now law,
and I was pointing that saying,
we don't want to do that.
You don't understand.
You've built social constructionism into
the law.
That means that now it's illegal to be a
biologist.
Well then everybody said,
oh,
no,
no.
That's not happening.
It's like,
don't kid yourself when you put things
in the law,
things happen and we were accused not
only of being Nazis and that was part of
the reason that the,
the,
this,
this talk was shut down,
but also of being biological,
essentialist and biological essentialism
is the new buzzword for,
for Nazi essentially.
So please do I want to.
I want to correct you.
It's not that it's illegal to be a
biologist.
It's just illegal to be any good at it.
Oh,
okay.
Well that's even more effective I would
say.
Is there,
is there concern that putting biology as
fact?
Maybe it will get in the way of
civilization because we're supposed to
be moving past all of these issues.
We're supposed to be moving past these
things as we evolve.
We're supposed to be looking people as
being free to choose whatever gender
they like,
free to choose whatever sexual
orientation they like,
free to express themselves in any way,
and that by defining them by purely
biological terms were essentially
relying on the meat wagon to lead us
through civilization rather than the
mind.
That's great that you did a very good
job of outlining the credible case
against biological essentialism and
because it can deteriorate into
something like eugenics,
there's a real danger,
like a political danger on the side of
biological
terminus is a danger in denying it as
well because then we can't use our
rational minds to truly mitigate
whatever issues that we would have with
our biological urges.
That's the irony of this actually.
It is an argument to be made that we
need freedom from our biology.
Yes,
and we have the capacity to do it.
Most creatures wouldn't,
but the way human beings are
constructed,
we absolutely have the ability to be
rational about these things and decide
which things we want to bring into the
future,
but we can't do it if we don't discuss
these things in a subset of males are,
are biologically hyper aggressive.
You can identify them at two years of
age and they're the kids.
If you put a bunch of two year olds
together,
there's a small subset.
They're almost all males,
about five percent of males who will
kick hit bite and steel.
Okay.
So that's their biological programming,
let's say,
but the vast majority of them are
socialized by the time they're four
years old.
So that's amazing.
Yeah,
sure.
Absolutely.
Absolutely it is.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And the thing about about boys like is
that if you
socialize them properly,
it's quite a bit of work because they're
very combative.
My son was like that,
and if you socialize them properly,
then they can become unbelievably
useful.
They're courageous,
they're forthright,
they're,
you know,
they're not going to back down from a
challenge.
There's all sorts of massive utility in
that.
And that's this proper interplay between
the biological circuitry and the
socialization,
but you know,
and,
and with James Demaurice memo,
you know,
he,
he was,
he's been accused of taking a biological
essentialist route,
which is not true.
One of the things James said is,
look,
there's credible evidence that there are
biologically mediated differences
between men and women at the level of
temperament and interest that are
actually large and profound.
And I would say the science on that is
sufficiently settled so that someone can
come out and say that scientifically
credible.
Now that doesn't mean it's right because
the scientists could be wrong,
but what you can't say is that what
James said was scientifically
uninformed.
It was scientifically informed,
but he also said,
look,
let's make the assumption,
I'm paraphrasing slightly,
but let's make the assumption that we
want to,
as a society,
we want to extract maximum useful
economic value from talented people.
So one of the things we want to do is if
some of those people are women in some
of them are men,
we want to understand the actual
differences between women and men so
that we can set up the workplace so that
both women and men can contribute to the
maximum economically so that they can
benefit as individuals and everybody can
benefit socially.
So you can use the biological.
So I mean,
for example,
one of the things,
here's,
here's a biological problem.
On average women are more agreeable than
men and I think that's because agreeable
people are their self sacrificing and I
think as a woman you need to be wired to
be self sacrificing or you won't be able
to tolerate taking care of infants.
That's my sense of it.
Okay.
Now there's some problems with that.
It's like,
let's say that a huge part of female
wiring is tilted in the direction of the
necessity of self sacrifice for infant
care.
Okay.
That doesn't equip women very well for
dealing with aggressive meant because of
aggressive men and infants are not the
same creatures.
So women play a pay,
a price being optimized to some degree
for infant care.
They pay a price that they're less,
uh,
what would you call prepared?
That's one way of thinking about it.
Indeed,
with dealing with hyper aggressive and
competitive meant,
well,
one of the consequences of that is that
agreeable people don't make as much
money and the reason for that is to make
money.
You actually have to be disagreeable
because you have to go to your boss and
say,
give me some bloody money or something
you don't like will happen to you.
You have to leave.
You have to be able to fight for an idea
too.
But so there's something that,
this is a perfect test case.
So biologically speaking,
there's a very good reason for certain
kinds of wisdom to be biased in the
direction of manifesting in females,
females,
because they have the capacity to have
fewer offspring,
a lifetime
than males,
uh,
are uh,
obligated,
as you say,
to um,
to care in a particular way.
And the fact that care and human beings
take so many years has resulted in
menopause emerging and menopause.
Essentially,
when a woman is done producing new
offspring,
her interests in her evolutionary
interest,
which in this case I think our honorable
becomes synonymous with the lineage,
the population,
because her offspring will either do
well or do poorly based on the
population that they're in.
So women have a kind of farsightedness
about lineage and I don't think it has
anything to do with human women
actually.
This is a trait that we can see in
females of other species.
So it's an ancient thing.
Whereas males are high variance.
That is to say a male can have many
offspring in a lifetime.
Many males have no offspring in a
lifetime,
and that high variance means that to the
extent that there is wisdom that
surrounds risk taking that has traveled
historically,
uh,
along the male path.
Now in modern times,
there's no reason that we can't look at
these two kinds of wisdom and
democratize them both,
right?
The fact is there's no reason if you're
born female,
that you can't tune into what has
historically been a male biased wisdom
and take advantage of that.
And we should be encouraging this.
There's no reason that people have to.
The problem is is that we can't actually
have a reasonable discussion about it
because you know,
the discussion is often for stalled by
the claim that well,
men and women are exactly the same.
It's like it's,
that's not a helpful discussion and you
know,
with the agreeableness issue,
I don't know exactly what should be done
about that,
but one of the consequences of it is,
is that there's many reasons why,
why the pay.
There's pay differential between men and
women and the issue itself is very
complex,
but we do know that agreeable people
overall make less money in the same
positions and it's because they don't
negotiate on their own behalf very well.
Now it's conceivable that you could have
an intelligent public policy or
corporate policy discussion about what
to do about that.
Like maybe,
maybe the rule is something like you
review male salaries once a year and
female salaries every eight months or
something like that.
You know,
and I'm not saying that's a good idea.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that if you,
if you take the facts on the ground into
account,
there are ways that you might be able to
use them so that you could,
and I'm not going to say level the
playing field because I think that's an
appalling phrase,
but maximize the possibility of economic
contribution across the genders,
which is obviously in everyone's best
interest,
but we're not going to do that when when
someone like James Damore comes out and
he's no scientist,
you know,
well,
he.
He has some scientific training,
but that wasn't his primary field of
expertise.
He came out and did a pretty credible
job of summarizing the literature.
He did it because he had been subject to
mandatory diversity training and was
asked to produce a response.
He didn't do it so it would go viral
within the company or become public and
because he expressed his opinion,
let's imperfectly.
He got fired.
It's like,
that's not good,
man.
That's not.
That's not a good pathway.
Will also wasn't good that his stuff was
being republished without citations.
That people were.
Were publishing it without the
scientific papers that were sort of
affirming.
What are some of the things that he was
saying?
I couldn't make heads or tails of it
until I saw his original version.
That goes back to the point I was making
earlier about this being this is an
unstable time where people's individual
ethical choices in some circumstances
will have effects far beyond the local.
It's like those journalists who jumped
on the story did it either badly,
you know,
because they were incompetent or they
did it maliciously and that and,
and so.
Now we could say,
let's say things go really badly in the
next year.
Well then each of those journalists
might be able to sit at home and say,
Hey,
I played a causal role in bringing about
this state of murderous collapse because
of my little ethical,
my ethical lapse when I was covering the
James Damore memo,
you know,
because of my own laziness and
ideological rigidity.
I was willing to play fast and loose
with the truth.
And now I've played a major causal role
and you know,
pushing everything towards a state of
chaos.
It's like people had better be on their
toes because we're in a situation that's
radically unstable and so it's time.
It's a really good time for everybody to
be very careful about what they write
and say and about their motives for,
for tarring and feathering the
opposition.
That's another way of.
Another thing that we have to be very
careful about.
It's just very bizarre how quick people
are to call someone a racist today.
I mean,
I've never seen anything like it in all
my years.
It's,
it's a strange time.
You know,
I got into it yesterday just I got bored
and I started trolling with pepe the
frog.
I started putting up the frog with
rainbow saying this seems like a frog
that's really into gay rights.
Like here's a frog that holding a lemon
with a tart face.
Like this is a frog that ate a lemon and
he's reacting to it.
Like how has this all racist?
Like how is this like anyone.
It's not like all these people that are
creating this frog are coordinating.
Anyone can make a meme with the frog and
like a lot of the original feels good
man cartoons that the guy created,
the,
those are applicable to their,
their silly,
a lot of them are really silly,
but I think a lot of it wasn't
intentional troll.
Yes.
So I read a story about Keka Stan,
you know,
I was looking into it trying to figure
out if it was really,
you know,
the menace to humanity that everybody
claims it is.
And the story was preposterous.
It was a magical place where were
antisemites and Jews and atheists and
religious people live in harmony,
which is like,
that's hard to even parse.
It's designed to,
to cause your mind to throw an error.
Well not is what.
So I think this is an excellent thing to
talk about because I've been,
because I've been,
let's say,
identified under many circumstances now
with the.
All right,
I've been doing every bit of
investigation I can into its many
manifestations.
It's a very confusing place.
It's certainly not an organized place
and exactly what it is is by no means
obvious.
And the Keck Estann issue is a good case
in point because mostly that's,
that's like a satirical realm where,
where,
where I don't know what it is.
It's late,
it's late,
it's defensive humor in some sense.
Let me give you an example.
I gave my father a Pakistani flag about
three weeks ago,
three weeks ago.
And when you do that well,
because he's been following what's
happening to me online,
you know,
and,
and I got associated with the frog in a
major way and it's a crazy story.
I won't go into it,
but I wore a frog hat on one of my
videos that an Indian carver and native
American carver had given me and he had
told me that the frog was in their
culture,
a harbinger of environmental
instability.
Because if the water's polluted at all,
the frogs die first.
So the frog,
the frog is the creature in their
mythology that warns the society that
things are out of kilter.
It's the canary in the coal mine,
the canary in the coal mine.
So I wore this frog hat and I made this
video about things being unstable and
I'd been identified with kermit because
my voice sort of sounds like kermit the
frog and it actually does.
So I've been making jokes about that.
And so then I made this video with this
frog hat and the frog that my carver
friend made actually had read lips and
then I made the video and as soon as I
posted it,
people said that's pepe.
And I thought I just about fainted
literally because it never occurred to
me that that was a connection.
So anyways,
I've been tangled in with this frog
thing in this most absolutely insane and
surreal manner,
but I've been so.
And that got me into the Pakistani thing
and a lot of the people that I'm trying
to address online are young men who are
pushed,
I would say in a right leaning direction
by the movement of the radical left
alienating.
And then they're thinking,
well,
I'm certainly not that.
Well then what am I?
Well maybe I'm the opposite of that.
Well,
is the opposite of the radical left the
alt right or is there a better opposite?
Is there a different opposite that
people could flee to?
And partly that's what I'm trying to
figure out.
But does it have to be opposite it?
Couldn't it just be different?
Well that's good question.
The opposition is a real issue with
people,
right?
Like what you were talking about before,
when people just ramp up their positions
and get more ideologically based and
they're doing it as a reaction to the
other side instead of just being who
they are instead of having some sort of
a personal sovereignty,
they are literally reacting to the side
changing who they are.
So okay.
So what I've been trying to do with my
videos and,
and,
and I think this is part of the reason
that they've become so popular.
In fact,
I'm certain of it,
is that I've been trying to agitate for
the adoption of that personal
responsibility as an alternative to
political ideology.
It's like get your act together,
have a vision,
straighten out your life.
Say what you think,
you know,
stay away from the ideological idiocies
and simplicity
and oversimplifications and try to put
yourself together because I think that I
do believe that the most fundamental
level,
and I think this is the remarkable
realization of Western civilization,
is that the well developed individual is
the antidote to the tyranny of society
and biology.
I think that's our great discovery in
the West.
It's not like other cultures haven't had
that idea in nascent form,
but it's been hyper developed in the
west and I think it's right.
And so we abandoned that,
that,
that pathway of divine individuality and
revert to ideological identification of
race or sex.
We're going to tear each other apart.
And I think part of the reason we're
motivated to do that,
Joe,
is because many people don't want to
bear the responsibility of developing
themselves as individuals.
So they'll,
they'll shuffle off the responsibility
and if that means that,
you know,
we're dancing in the streets because
everything's on fire,
that'll be just fine.
And that's another thing that's adding
to the terrible danger that we're in
right now.
So I think you're right,
and I think that personal auditing
program that you,
you're a part of is gigantic and people
look at it as being separate from all
these issues that we're dealing with
culturally,
but I don't think it is.
I think you're absolutely right and I
think that there is a real lack of
struggle and understanding of struggle
with a lot of people today.
Not necessarily struggled financially,
but I mean like physical struggles,
spiritual struggle,
understanding that you have to overcome
difficult issues to really understand
the true potential of your mind and your
body.
You have to not only overcome them,
but you have to seek them out
voluntarily.
And,
and,
and what would you say exalt in the fact
that they exist and that's part of
bearing the burden of being.
It's like being as a tragic state,
human being is a tragic state,
so you can shrink from that,
but if you shrink from that,
the suffering increases and intensifies
and you become resentful and malevolence
yes.
So the alternative is to move forward
courageously.
That's the Dragon Motif,
right?
That's the hero myth essentially.
And that is the pathway forward as far
as I'm concerned.
It has implications,
you know,
you're,
you're talking about it at the level of
what is best for the individual.
But we also have a problem which is that
these collectivist movements,
whether they are,
you know,
a white nationalists on the right or a
social justice warriors on the left,
they cannot see forward.
And what is missing is that actually the
mechanism that allows us to discover new
ways involves individuals who are
capable of thinking independently.
And if you have multiple individuals who
think independently about related
matters,
then they can pull that stuff.
But if what we do is we force everybody
to sign up for the same things that we
all agree are true.
There is no way of discovering what we
don't yet know because every great idea
starts with a minority of one.
So we have to have the freedom to be the
only person who believes something and
then to compel others that
it's somewhere in the right neighborhood
and for others to pick up that mantle.
And so by subordinating.
That's exactly why.
I mean,
free speech is becoming an ideological
issue and increasingly identified with,
with the right in,
which is horrible.
It's horrifying,
but the right justification for free
speech is what you just laid out,
which is that in order for like the
collective is a group of what's already
known by definition,
we inhabit the collective and that's
what's already known,
what we could agree on.
But the problem with that is that what
we can agree on what's already known
isn't sufficient because we still have
problems so people have to be out at the
fringes,
on the border between chaos and order
where they discover new things and
communicated back to the collective
which free speech does that.
That's the mechanism.
This is,
this is also at a deep evolutionary
truth,
which is that all of the innovations
that allow,
whether we're talking about one
creature,
learning to do some new trick that gives
rise to a bunch of species that do the
same trick or whether we're talking
about population is discovering a new
way to live,
uh,
on earth.
All of these things proceed from the
fringe,
right?
The people at the center for whom things
are working best aren't going to be the
ones to innovate the new way.
It's people for whom things are not
quite working that are going to innovate
new ways and that that's also true for a
population of frogs or birds or plants
or whatever.
The ones that are not well situated are
the ones where an experiment can pay
off.
That's why hands eyes and Keke.
Psychologist wrote a good book called
Genius and he was interested in what
predicted high levels of creative
success and some of it's what you'd
expect.
Iq is one of them and creative
temperament is another,
but losing a parent before the age of 10
was a nice predictor.
And you know,
people think about creativity as if it's
all sweetness and light.
It's like no bloody way,
man.
If you're going to be creative,
it's because you're tormented by a
problem.
Right?
And so if you're not in a position to be
tormented by a problem,
you're not going to put it in the time
and effort and take the risk necessarily
necessary to be creative.
So,
but you know,
I've been trying to understand the
evolutionary landscape out of which our
most fundamental religious convictions
emerge and the idea that it is by
definition the individual that innovates
and that by definition therefore it's
the individual that's the savior of the
collective.
I mean,
it's hard to.
It's hard to imagine how you could find
a biological restatement of an essential
Christian presupposition that was more
mapped one to one than that.
Now you could say,
well,
that's not unique to Christianity.
I see the same thing in the Judaism,
in the Jewish antithesis between the
prophetic tradition,
the profit and the tradition,
because the profit is always the lone
voice,
right?
That comes out.
It happens over and over in the Old
Testament alone.
Voice comes out and challenges the king
and says,
look,
you know,
you're,
you're a blind tyrant and nature is
moving away from us and preparing her
revenge and you better watch the hell
out because you're violating the
intrinsic moral norms and you're going
to pay for it.
That happens over and over and maybe
there are 50 of them and the one that
gets recorded as the one that happened
to be closest to,
right?
Because that's the population that gets
through the bottleneck.
And so,
you know,
what we have is sort of evolution
offering,
uh,
these texts in a way.
Yes.
Well that's,
that's,
that's a claim that I'm very,
what would you call a,
um,
that,
that's something I believe to be
fundamentally true.
And I mean I've started,
I started because I'm interested in this
idea of strengthening the individually.
That's when I,
when I wrote my first book maps of
meaning it was about ideological
conflict and it was about whether or not
there was any alternative to ideological
conflict because you could make a case
that there isn't.
There's.
Right.
And there's laughter and there's a war,
right?
But there is a third way and I think
that is the way of the heroic individual
and I mean that technically and that
that involves the development of
individual character so that you can say
what it is that you think that you can
articulate your experience properly and
that you can bring what it is that's
unique to you into the collective
landscape and that's what updates the
collective landscape.
It's absolutely vital.
And so I started doing these biblical
lectures,
Say I've done 12 of them now walking
through genesis and what I'm trying to
do because I believe that the Bible is
the documentation of the emergence of
the idea of the divine individual.
That's essentially what it is.
And we.
We have a very uneasy relationship with
that collection of texts now because
the.
We read them as if they're making claims
about the objective nature of the world
and those claims seem to be false.
From a scientific perspective.
I don't believe that those are the
claims that were made to begin with.
So I think it's a nonstarter.
But I've been trying to lecture about
the stories in Genesis.
For example,
in a manner that makes them accessible
to people who are well to athe who to
atheists,
let's say,
and many,
many atheists have been responding very
positively to them.
I have people in my youtube comments now
that are calling themselves Christian
atheists because they can understand,
they understand what it is I'm.
I'm describing this idea that's emerged
in the west.
That consciousness is the mediator
between chaos and order and the and the
and the generating the phenomena that
generates experience and that and that.
You can think about that as as a,
as a divine category of of existence and
I've been trying to delineate how,
how the biblical stories layout the
pathway by which the divine individuals
should manifest him or herself in time
because that is what it is and I,
and I've,
I've,
I've been studying for example,
the abrahamic stories which I didn't
know well,
and the abrahamic stories are really
interesting.
I mean,
Abraham is called by God and when
Abraham is called by God,
he's old.
He's like one of these guys who's 40
years old and he stayed in his mother's
basement.
That's,
that's Abraham.
It's a little late for Abraham to be
getting the hell out there in the world
and God basically says to him,
leave your family and your friends and
your place of comfort and journey into
the land of the stranger.
That's the call to adventure,
and so Abraham does that.
Now he's chosen by God.
You think,
well,
everything goes well for Abraham.
That isn't what happens at all.
The first thing he encounters is a
famine and to escape that he flees into
the tyranny of Egypt where they tried to
steal his wife,
so beware of being called by God.
You know,
you'd think it'd be all sweetness and
light after that.
It's not bad at all and it's very
realistic story.
It's like,
get the hell out of where you're safe
into what you don't know.
Well,
what are you going to find there while
you're fortunate?
No,
you're going to find the catastrophes of
life,
but if you keep yourself morally
oriented and you make the right
sacrifices,
which is the,
the Abrahamic story to a t,
then you can transcend the catastrophe
of being and prevail.
I mean,
it's,
who the hell doesn't want to hear that?
So we're treading kind of close to the,
uh,
the argument you got into with Sam
Harris about the nature of truth.
And since I heard that I've been sort of
itching to have this conversation with
you because I think there's a way of
viewing this that will actually perhaps
reconcile the two points of view,
but there's a bitter pill that comes
along with it.
So here's,
here's my argument.
Um,
we tend to think of intellect has
evolved as having evolved because
knowing what's true gives you an
advantage,
but there's actually nothing that says
that the literal truth is where
advantage lies.
And so I have a category that I call
literally false,
metaphorically true.
These are ideas that aren't true in the
factual sense,
but they are true enough that if you
behave as if they were true,
you'd come out ahead of where you would
be if you behaved according to the fact
that they're not true.
So let me give you a couple of trivial
examples that won't be controversial.
Porcupines can throw their quilts,
not true.
However,
if you live near porcupines and you
imagine that porcupines can throw their
quills,
you'll give them some space.
If you don't,
you may realize that they can't throw
their quills get really close to one and
it may wheel around and nail you with a
porcupine quill,
which can be extremely dangerous because
they are microscopically designed to
move in from where they puncture you
over time and they can puncture a vital
organ or you can get an infection.
So the person who believes that a
porcupine can throw their quills has an
advantage that isn't predicated on the
fact that this is actually a literal
truth,
right?
Um,
another one might be a.
people say everything happens for a
reason,
right?
Well,
unless you're talking about physics as
the reason everything doesn't happen for
a reason.
However,
if you are the kind of person who
believes that everything happens for a
reason and then some terrible tragedy
befalls you,
you may be on the lookout,
well,
what's the reason that this happened?
Maybe it's supposed to open some
opportunity and you won't miss that
opportunity.
The way somebody who was preoccupied
with their misfortune would so literal
falseness,
but metaphorical truth is actually,
I would argue the category under which
religious truth evolves.
Now the problem,
the bitter pill that I mentioned is that
I've heard you say that the truths that
are captured in the religious version of
things,
um,
are basically like,
uh,
you know,
there's an individual truth and then
there's a truth of your family and
there's a truth of the population that
you're living in.
And these things are all encoded in
these,
these doctrines which is true,
and you would expect it to be because
the doctrines are carried along in the
population.
The problem is,
what I hear you arguing when you tell me
if I have it wrong,
is that we should therefore expect the
encoded metaphorical truths in these
religious traditions to be morally
right.
But there's nothing that actually says
it will be morally right because there
are metaphorical trues that might in
fact be reprehensible,
but nonetheless effective.
And so what I would argue,
the overarching point here would be that
you're right,
that the documents that contain these
descriptions of things are full of
things that are true in some sense that
is not literal scientific truth norwest
up their,
their purpose.
What isn't true is that those things are
inherently uptodate.
Okay?
I mean,
first of all,
the first thing about that is that a
discussion like that,
and this is also what happened with Sam
Harris,
takes me to the very limits of my
intellectual ability.
And so even in discussing it,
I'm going to make all sorts of mistakes
because,
because it's treacherous territory.
But I would say my understanding of the
great myths has that observation built
into it.
So one of the archetypes is that of the,
of the tyrannical father,
which is the archetype by the way,
that possesses the minds of people who
accused Western Society of being
patriarchal.
They're possessed by a singular
archetype.
And that's the archetype of the
tyrannical father.
They don't see that there's a tyrannical
father and a wise king because there is,
that's,
that's.
You can't even point that out.
But anyways,
in the old,
in some of our oldest stories,
there's a representation of the dead
past.
So let me give you an example that
everyone knows about.
The Story of Pinocchio is the story of
the individualization of Pinocchio.
He starts out as a puppet.
He's a Marionette,
he's a wooden head,
he's a liar,
and he's pulled by forces that he does
not understand.
Right?
Okay.
So.
But he has a good father that's Japan
and so he's got a good and Japan to wish
is that he becomes a real individual and
so,
and he knows that that's an impossible,
which he wishes on a star,
that his son could become an actual
individual knowing full well that that's
unlikely and impossible.
So Japan was a good king.
So.
But the story is also about Japan
because what happens is that when Japan
will loses Pinocchio,
loses his son,
which will,
you could think about as the active
dynamic,
attentive force of youth.
Then he ends up stultified in the belly
of a whale,
which is a symbol of chaos at the bottom
of the ocean and in Pinocchio has to
rescue him.
So I would say there is an instantiation
of evolutionarily accumulated wisdom in
the great stories of the past,
but they're still dead and it requires
the union.
This is why in Christian theology that
God had has a tripartite structure.
This is part of the reason there's God
the father,
but the father's dead,
the father was right 100 years ago or
thousand years ago,
and it's still partly right,
but he's dead.
He can't participate in the updating of
the process.
So you need an active force.
Now the active force is the same thing
that generated those stories across
time,
right?
So it's the same thing except it's also
alive in the present.
And so your moral duty,
and this is another thing that happens
in,
in Pinocchio,
is to rescue your dead father from the
belly of the whale.
And that's partly what I'm trying to do
with these biblical lectures because
you're objection is correct.
The reason it's correct is because even
if the solution was correct,
the landscape has changed and it's
changed incrementally or in a
revolutionary way.
We don't know.
And so those old truths are at best
partial.
And at worst blind,
but that doesn't mean you can just say
like,
like mounted did during the Cultural
Revolution will let's just destroy the
past.
It's like,
no,
that would be like saying,
well,
you don't need a body anymore because
your body is the collected wisdom of the
evolutionary process across three and a
half billion years.
I absolutely agree.
Because the stories are not literal.
It's impossible to know whether they.
Well not impossible,
but very difficult to know whether or
not the truth that is contained
metaphorically is still relevant.
If it's been inverted and it's now
absolutely false.
Or Carl Jung talked about this a lot.
Hey,
and one of the things he said was that
your moral duty is to realize the
archetype in the,
in the confines of your own life.
And so you say,
well,
there's an archetype of perfection that
pervades the west.
And for the,
for the sake of argument,
I'm going to call that Christ the Christ
image.
It's something like that.
That's the archetypal image.
Now we have a story about what Christ's
historical life was like.
Well,
well,
well you can't have that life because
you would've had to be in the Middle
East 2000 years ago.
That's not your life,
but what you can do is take the
archetype and you can manifest.
It was within the confines of your own
life and what that does is force you to
undergo the difficult process of
updating the ancient wisdom and you
don't just forego it.
You can't or you can,
but you'll pay a massive price and part
of that'll be social disintegration
because it's.
It's the past is alive enough so that
those of us who inhabit its corpse
aren't clawing each other to death.
Well,
we're feeding right.
That's the critical issue.
Now it's not alive enough because the
bloody thing could fall apart at any
moment and we need to be awake and alert
in order to keep it updated and
maintained well.
Not only that,
but they're the greatest hazards to us
in the present are only partially going
to be dealt with in these texts.
And that's,
that's my biggest concern is that if we
take a,
you know,
dawkins dismissing religion,
his mind virus,
this is very dangerous because it
neglects the truth that you're talking
about and it prevents us from getting to
a conversation in which we can talk
about the fact that religious texts,
religions are not mind viruses,
they are adaptations to past
environments they do contain a kind of
truth that isn't necessarily literal and
is in general,
not literal,
but none of them know ancient religion
is uptodate for Google's algorithms
being the hazard to civilization that it
probably is.
We need to figure out how to navigate
where the ancestral wisdom is simply not
up to the current challenge.
Okay,
so let,
let me modify that slightly because I
think it's true and not true.
The stories are erroneous in detail and
write in pattern.
So for example,
there's an idea that one of the things
that the mythological hero does is stand
up against the tyranny of the state.
Now you don't have to specify the nature
of the tyranny of the state in order for
that to be a truth that's applicable
across different context.
Now,
I would say what's happened with the
great religious myths is that they've
operated level of obstruction such that
the abstract entities are applicable in
every single environment.
I'll give you an example of that.
It is extremely useful to represent the
phenomenology of your experience as a
domain of chaos and order that works in
every single environment for every
person and so the domain of order,
I can describe it.
Technically you're in the domain of
order.
When your actions produce the result you
desire and you're in the domain of chaos
when they don't,
and then and then I could say,
well,
your task is to straddle the border
between those two domains because you
don't always want to be where everything
that you're doing is working because you
don't learn anything and you don't want
to be where nothing you're doing is
working because it's overwhelming.
You want to be stable and dynamic at the
same point,
and the Dallas do that very nicely
because they have a chaos order,
conceptualization of the,
of the phenomenal logical landscape and
their claim is the point of maximum
proper being is right at the center of
the border between chaos and order and I
think that's true across contexts.
So I don't think that truth ages,
some of them don't,
but the question really is one of at
what point is there so much legacy code
that the taking the package is a is more
harmful than it is beneficial and at
what point are,
you know,
if God were writing today,
I'm pretty convinced the first
commandment would be thou shalt not
enriched uranium.
It would make sense as the number one
commandment.
It's not there because uranium wasn't a
a concept at the point that the thing
was written or was the hazard of
enriching it obvious.
And so the fact that it isn't mentioned
tends to deemphasize it as a risk.
And so I guess the question is,
is it possible?
I mean,
is it possible that by recognizing that
these traditions carry huge amounts of
ancestral wisdom forward,
but that,
that wisdom is certain to be so
incomplete that it doesn't address
modern questions that we can be
liberated to move forward and to honor
those traditions for bringing us here,
but to recognize that we actually have
to move forward with something more
potent and uptodate,
which is not not easy because you can't
just take the scientific truth of the
moment and implemented a lot of it isn't
even.
Right.
So yeah,
it's also not that easy to rewrite a
fairytale,
you know,
and some of these fairytales that people
are trying to rewrite in modern times or
perhaps 15,000
years old and people think,
well we can just update that so that the
modern version will be better.
It turns out that that's very,
very difficult.
And there's another.
I'm going to play devil's advocate
against my own position here.
You know,
because I say,
well,
the religious texts in code profiling
and evolutionarily determined truths
that are universal.
Okay.
Which religious texts,
right?
That's not true.
Well,
because you might say,
well all of them,
but then that means that obscures the
important differences between the
traditions and I'm by no means certain
that all of them do,
you know,
so I'm going to stick my neck way the
hell out because why not?
It isn't obvious to me that Islam does
because I.
it's very difficult for me to see that
the totalizing nature of Islam doesn't
make it unique among religions.
So now good.
So.
Well there's that out on the tape if
you don't mind.
What isn't the issue using the word
truth?
Because we can say we could use
tradition and wisdom and we're okay,
but as soon as we start saying truth,
then,
then we run into problems.
I mean,
and even when you're talking about
porcupines where you're talking about
what would you say metaphorical truth
versus,
look,
it's not true.
It's real simple.
Just don't go near the porcupine teach.
The kid did not go near the porcupine
because porcupine quills are dangerous.
They get stuck in you.
They're really dangerous.
Can they throw it at you know they
cannot,
but just stay clear of them because you
don't want them to somehow another get
in touch with your body.
There's no truth in that.
They can throw their quills at you.
You benefit from being particularly
aware of the dangers of their quills,
but if you tell a kid that they can
throw their quills and so therefore the
kid stays clear of him.
He has a faulty assumption in his head.
You're lying to them for their own
protection and I was not good.
I wouldn't do it.
The the same thing can be said of
everything happens for a reason.
Well,
here's the problem.
We don't know if everything happens for
a reason.
Maybe when you die,
you go to some auditing room and they
go,
well,
you know,
it's all just a part of some gigantic
algorithm that you impossible.
It's impossible for you to understand
duty or limited processing power of the
human brain.
You're dealing with some semyon,
sort of a complex geometry that is
really just designed to keep your body
moving and keep you alive and spread
your genetics so that you can eventually
evolve to the point when you're a god.
Well,
first of all,
I.
I have kids.
I wouldn't tell them that a porcupine,
I'm sure will,
but how,
but why use the word truth though?
Because.
Well,
the question is why do people tell you
that a porcupine him through it's quilt?
I don't.
I don't think they do.
Oh,
they do.
Well,
if they do,
they don't know any better.
Right?
Or they're liars and so all I'm saying
is that actually that is likely to be
the product of selection.
In other words,
that those people who had encoded that
they do throw their quills have an
advantage.
It's not the way I would do it and for
exactly the reason that you point out
which is if you give a child the wrong
model of a porcupine,
don't know whether a porcupine is liable
to be the gateway to some more important
question,
but if it were,
you've just steered the kid wrong.
Something here's part of the problem,
and this is part of this is a really big
problem.
There's two things I guess,
that were brought up by what you
described in the first is the
terminology of truth.
Now Harris,
his claim with regards to my utilization
of truth was that I was absconding with
the definition of truth and false
matter,
but he was wrong because the idea of
truth is much older than the idea of
objective truth and the original notion
of truth wasn't objective.
True.
It was like the Arrow flies straight and
true.
It had meant something like reliably,
reliably,
on its way to the appropriate
destination,
something like that,
and when Christ said,
I am the truth and the way what I can
remember of it.
Yes,
yes,
it's the truth he was talking about
wasn't an objective truth.
So Sam's idea that I had somehow taken
the idea of truth that was actually
objective all along and done something
crooked with it is just wrong.
It's wrong.
Well,
the truth can have multiple definitions.
That's the issue and that's exactly what
we're.
What we're trying to get at here is like
there's,
to me,
there's two kinds of truth and and they
may be,
they may be commensurate,
you may be able to stack them on top of
one another,
but now and then they dissociate and
this is actually what what,
what Brett was referring to as well,
so,
and this is where it gets so complicated
that I can barely manage it.
There's a,
there's the truth that manifests itself
in the manner in which you act and
as a representation of the objective
world and sometimes both those truths
are stacked on top of each other and
sometimes they're not.
So like I could give you a piece of
wisdom that would work well if you acted
it out,
that carried within it and inaccurate
representation of part of the objective
world.
And you could say,
well maybe that's actually the case with
the biblical stories because if you read
them as science,
they don't read well.
So let's take malaria as a good example.
Malaria.
The root of the word is mal area,
bad air,
right?
Malaria is not transmitted by bad air,
it's transmitted by mosquitoes that live
in places where you might think the air
is bad,
so the point is it's part of the way
there.
Yeah,
that's.
That's a good one,
and then not also gets.
See.
There's another weird distinction here
and that I was trying to draw with Sam,
but it's a really tricky one.
We augured in because we started to talk
about pragmatism,
but there's also something like the
truth of a description and the truth of
the tool and my sense is that people's
fundamental truths are tool like we use
them to function properly in the world
and you could say,
well a sharp ax is more true than a dull
ax and actually you can use the word
true in that sense.
That actually isn't appropriate
appropriate use of the word there.
There are tool truths and there are
objective factors now and in the optimal
circumstance,
those map onto each other,
but we're not smart enough often to make
the map onto each other because we just
don't know enough and there are lots of
truths that we have that portray the
objective world improperly that are
still true.
Is the problem using the term true when
sometimes you should use the term fact
like one plus one is two.
That is a fact.
One plus one is two is also true.
You throw some water on a match.
That is and it'll go out.
That's a fact.
Yes.
Well,
I see it.
At least there is this overarching
truth,
the one that Sam Harris was pointing to,
the one I think you're pointing to also,
and the one I'm,
I'm imagining we all subscribed to,
right?
There is the testable truth that reveals
itself in the laboratory or in a careful
experiment in the field.
And that really is the top level truth.
But then there are the truths you can't
speak yet.
So let's take the word filth from,
uh,
from the Old Testament.
Okay?
Filth means shit.
Right,
you're not supposed to shit in camp
because God finds it offensive.
Now,
the problem is the germ theory of
disease doesn't come about for thousands
of years after that truth was written.
That truth keeps you from infecting
people long before you can ever explain
that there are microbes that grow in
humans.
Shit that,
or a particular danger to your
population.
So the point is,
would you rather be held back to the
place where you can actually describe
the,
the literal underpinnings of what's
going on?
Or do you want to be liberated to say
something that actually results in a,
an improvement in health before you
know,
literally thousands of years before
anybody had any idea that it was
microbes at the root of this.
So you need to figure out so.
So an elaboration of that would be
something like human beings needed to
figure out how to act without dying
before they could understand the nature
of the world well enough to justify that
and somebody be crazy.
Now that we do have the germ theory of
disease to to amplify that original
crude version of the truth or that crude
approximation of what you need to
believe in order to behave safely,
there's no reason for that truth to be
promoted.
In fact,
you don't hear people describing this
part of the the old testament anymore
because it's not relevant,
right?
This is probably all wide.
Dietary restrictions were in the old
testament as well as shellfish,
red tide eating pigs trick and gnosis.
There's a lot,
a lot of issues that go along with that,
right?
Well,
there is some intermingling perhaps of
hygienic concerns with also the desire
for the groups to distinguish themselves
from other groups.
Right?
Because you can.
You can unite your group quite tightly
by dietary restrictions.
So I'm back to your point about
terminology.
You know,
we could,
we could do something like fact and
wisdom.
Will you say truth.
That's the overarching category.
And then that divides into fact and
wisdom and what you want optimally as
you want the facts and the wisdom to be
one on one to one,
but often they're not.
And if you find wisdom where the facts
aren't laid right out,
you don't just get to throw away the
wisdom,
which is what I think happens in the
case of people like Dawkins and Harris
and Harris makes another sleight of hand
move,
which I don't like,
which is that he thinks so,
let's say,
except for just a second,
the wisdom fact distinction.
He would say,
well,
the fact is the thing and the wisdom is
a second order derivation of that.
You can ground the wisdom and the fact,
and I don't believe that,
and I don't think that he has any.
I don't think that he has any real
justification for that claim.
And this is something I never thought he
would even by grounding the wisdom in
the fact thinks,
if you know the facts clearly enough,
you'll know how to act well.
That's not necessarily true.
Well,
there's,
there's ways to act with that are within
your best interest.
And then there's ways to act that are
within the interest of all the people
around you been might not serve you that
well.
Well,
there's also a distinction is where
ethics come,
right,
or what the consequences are delayed
some number of generations.
Sure,
yes.
Well that's a big problem.
And so,
so sam acts as if the process of Mac
mapping facts onto action is simple.
If we just got the facts right,
but,
but it's the weakest part of his
argument and we never ever got to that
for a variety of reasons,
but part of the reason it's weak is
okay,
well there's like an infinite number of
facts,
man.
Which so let's say you're standing in
front of a field and you're looking at
the field,
the field does not tell you how to walk
through it.
There's a million ways through the field
and no matter how many facts about the
field you aggregate,
you're not going to be able to determine
the appropriate path by aggregating
those facts.
So that's.
And that that's a problem that I don't
think Sam is willing to take seriously
and well.
Well I think there are two problems
tangled up here.
One of them is,
there's a question of are is one
individual is supposed to have all of
the facts and navigate based on that
sort of the rationality community
version of things or does the practical
truth is we can't all be experts in
everything.
And so we have to go along with,
you know,
guides to our behavior that are
approximate and that's inherent.
And then there's a question about
civilization.
Civilization should be guided by our
best understanding of what's actually
true,
but with an understanding that we don't
have a complete map of a lot of stuff.
And so I think what you're pointing at
is that there is wisdom that has been
handed to us that is not such that we
can just simply say,
oh,
here's the nugget at the center of it
and we need to preserve that thing
because we don't necessarily know what
it's doing.
Um,
which is,
you know,
that's,
this is dangerous because some of what
it's doing may not be acceptable.
And then think about,
let's look at the wisdom end of things
for a minute and talk to you alluded a
little earlier too,
like iterations and about the fact that
things are integrated across time and
that's something that works now might
fail dreadfully in a month or two
months.
So.
So here's,
here's what something has to be like to
be wise,
let's say,
well first of all,
let's say it would be good if it was a
new accordance with the facts,
but we'll leave that aside for now.
It has to work.
If you operate according to the wisdom
principle,
whatever it is,
it has to work in the world,
but then it has to work in a world that
allows you to maintain your
relationships with people in the world.
Right?
So,
so it's all of a sudden this wisdom
thing is something that's not only
constrained by,
let's call it an objective reality,
but it's constrained by the necessity of
a social contract,
a functional social contract.
So you're only able to.
You're only allowed to put forward
actions in the world.
That would be a benefit to you if they
simultaneously don't undermine the
structure within which you live.
Okay,
and then there's a game theory element
to that which is,
well,
if it's wise than it works in the world,
so that'd be the constraint of objective
reality,
but then it works for you now and the
you that'll be in a week and the EU
that'll be in a month and it works for
you and your family and it works for you
and your family on society and it works
in a way that those things all line up
to be iterated across time.
And so this.
This is actually the also the solution
is for the.
I really like to hear what you think
about this.
I think this is the solution to the
postmodern conundrum because the
postmodernists bless their heart,
so we'll give the devil his due say,
well,
the problem is there's an infinite
number of interpretations of a finite
set of facts and the right response to
that is,
oh,
that's true.
That's true.
That's not good.
And that's why the postmodern is say,
well,
you can't agree on a canonical
interpretation of a great piece of
literature because the number of
potential interpretations are infinite,
and so then they say,
well why should we settle on any one
interpretation that why should we
privilege one over another?
And then they say,
well,
that's all power games.
And so that's what you got to take that
seriously.
But what they missed,
and this is a big deal,
it's a big deal I think is this idea of
of ethical constraint.
It's like,
yes,
there's a landscape of potentially
infinite interpretations,
but hardly any of them will work in the
real world and hardly any of them will
work in the real world in a way that
doesn't get you killed by other people
or do you because of your own stupidity
to failure across time.
And so the landscape of interpretation
is almost infinite,
but the landscape of applicable
interpretation,
functional interpretation is
unbelievably constraint.
And I think that constraint system is
what we regard as ethics.
It's something like that.
Well,
at some level,
stories continued through time for a
reason.
You know,
good stories continue for a long,
you know,
the Odyssey is with us for some reason
and we,
so there is a scientific reason or
scientifically investigated [inaudible]
reason why the Odyssey has been durable.
Um,
we may not know it,
but in principle it's a question you
could investigate.
Um,
so I guess at the,
at the end of the day,
the problem with the postmodernist is
that they have a point.
The point is perception gets in the way
of anything we wish to do objectively,
but that point only takes you so far and
that's why they turned to Marxism as far
as I can tell.
Because what happens with the
postmodernist is they say,
oh,
there's an infinite number of
interpretations.
And then the human part of them goes,
okay,
well what am I supposed to do next?
Then since there's an infinite number of
choices,
and the postmodernist says,
well,
my theory can't account for that.
And then they say,
well,
back to Marxism.
And so that's why I think there's this
unholy alliance between the
postmodernists and the new Marxists
because postmodernism is a is a dead end
from the perspective of applicable
wisdom.
It leaves you bereft and nihilistic and
that's not good because people can't
exist without a purpose.
And so they sneak the Marxism through
the back door and jump into this power
landscape for the reasons that we
discussed earlier.
So
I really think that it's because of an
infinite number of possibilities
interpretating things because I've
always felt that it was really just a
response to capitalism.
The capitalism is a very negative aspect
of our culture and society and that
there's got to be some sort of an
alternative.
Marxism is a clearly defined alternative
that other people have subscribed to in
the past.
You could point to it.
It's a structure that's already are
already set up and it's romanticized and
I think they adopted for that reason
because it has a socialist aspects
attached to it.
And they looked at socialism as some
sort of a thing that regards equality
and some sort of an egalitarian
approach.
Okay.
So we'd have to take two things apart,
we'd have to take Marxism slash neo,
Marxist,
Marxism and postmodernism apart.
So we could do that historically,
and I would say that although there is a
reason for postmodernism,
which is the reason we just discussed
that the landscape,
the infinite landscape of interpretation
problem,
it's a real problem if you look at it
historically,
postmodernism actually grew out of
Marxism and so what?
What?
What happened is that the Marxists laid
out their,
their,
their theory about the human social
environment being composed of a power
struggle between the privileged and the
underprivileged,
right?
The rich and the poor and in its initial
phases.
And that's a story that's partially true
and it's got a lot of motive power.
Like the motor power is the romantic
motive power that you just described.
I get to be on this side of the
oppressed.
I get to be a war.
You're for what's right.
There's the resentment element,
which is that son of a bitch has more
than me,
so let's cut them off at the knees,
which manifested itself brutally in the
Soviet Union.
And then there's the ideological
totality issue which gives people a
sense of security that took a vicious
hit by by the late 19 sixties because
the murderousness of Marxism had been
clearly laid out as a doctrine and that
opened the door to this move by by
mostly French intellectuals to to
develop the postmodern philosophy which
has these advantages which we described,
but also to use that as a screening
tactic for allowing Marxism to transform
into identity politics and so like it's
hard to disentangle all the motivations
there going on in there,
but there's something about it that's
that's truly intellectually pathological
because you don't get to be a
postmodernist and a Marxist.
You actually technically cannot be both
of those things at the same time.
And the fact that most people are both
of those things at an at the same time
raises the specter of just exactly what
their motivation is.
And then I would say it's this
resentment driven anti-capitalism.
There's reasons to criticize capitalism
obviously,
but it's this underground resentment
driven anti-capitalism.
That I think is one of the fundamental
motivators.
If I can,
if I can add a couple things,
the risk of alienating my last few
friends in for a penny I guess.
So here's the thing,
what?
What's up with the.
With Marxism is A.
There's a lot in mark's critique of
capitalism that's actually right and so
that Kinda gets you through the door
once you start looking at the analysis
and then there's the prescription which
is toxic,
but it's not obvious why it's toxic.
In other words,
it's a pretty good story that doesn't
happen to function and so people
gravitate to it because the story is
moderately compelling.
It's not game theoretically functional
or stable or viable and it does descend
into this kind of inevitable grave
violence and so we know that now
historically it's not just a theoretical
issue.
We've now seen enough of it to know that
as a fact,
but nonetheless the fact that there are
people telling the story to kids who
don't yet know what to do with something
that sounds like it might be true,
it is very dangerous.
If you don't mind break it down as to
why it goes bad.
Well,
I mean it's sort of a tired critique,
but I happen to think it's about right,
which is that it just does not take
account of what a human being is and
what makes society function spoken like
a true fascist biologically essentialist
wasn't very nice,
I think.
I think that is.
Well,
I think it might be related back to.
Okay,
so let's go back to the idea that marks
had something to say.
Okay.
And we could clarify that a little
bit.
So here's the problem.
This is the problem that that seems to
emerge as the function of some really
fundamental force that we don't quite
understand and that's this phenomena
that I've been referring to as the
prieto distribution.
Okay,
so here,
here's the,
here's the situation.
If you look at any creative endeavor
that human beings engage in,
so that would be an endeavor where
there's variability in individual
production and it doesn't matter what it
is.
Here's what happens.
People Compete to produce whatever that
is and almost everybody produces zero.
They lose completely.
A small minority are a tiny bit
successful and a hyper minority are
insanely successful.
And so the prieto distribution for the
prieto distribution is,
is the geometric graph representation of
that phenomena.
And so here's how it manifests itself.
If you have 10,000
people,
100 of them have half the money.
So the rule is the square root of the
number of people under consideration
have half of whatever it is that's under
consideration.
So this works everywhere.
So if you took 100 classical composers,
10 of them produce half the music that's
played,
and then if you take the 10 composers
and you take a thousand of their songs,
30 of those songs,
which is the square root of a thousand
roughly speaking,
are played 50 percent of the time.
And so there's this underlying natural
law which is expressed as the matthew
principle,
which is from a new testament statement.
The statement is to those who have
everything more will be given and from
those who have nothing,
everything will be taken.
It's a vicious statement,
but it's actually,
here's one of those places where it's
actually empirically true.
This happens everywhere.
And so what mark's observed was the
capital tended to accumulate in the
hands of fewer and fewer people,
and he said,
that's a flaw of the capitalist system.
That's wrong.
It's not a flaw of the capitalist
system.
It is a feature of every single system
of production that we know of,
no matter who set it up and how it
operates.
And so then now we have a problem
because what happens is as soon as you
set up a domain of production and you
need to,
because you need things to be produced,
then you instantly produce a competition
and the spoils go disproportionately to
a tiny percentage of people.
So then so then,
well,
so what?
Well,
so with the rest of the people starve or
the system becomes unstable because
everybody's mad.
It's like that's a big problem.
Okay,
so how do human beings fixed that?
Well,
the first thing we did was diversify the
number of productive games is so you
don't get to be NBA basketball star,
but you know,
you can run a podcast.
It's a completely different competitive
landscape.
So we can fractionate the the production
landscape,
and then people who aren't successful in
one domain might be successful in
others.
That's human creativity.
We're really good at that.
But the problem with that is you could
still get a positive correlation among
the successful people you know.
So because you're so successful.
For example,
with your podcast and your youtube
videos,
your connection network is insane,
insanely powerful,
right?
So you still have this tendency for
what's useful and good to be what
distributed,
let's call it inequitably and it's,
it's,
it's got the power of a physical law.
In fact,
there are people they call themselves
econo physicists.
No one knows that there's a field econo
physicists,
econo physics,
and they use the same mathematical
equations that represent the propagation
of molecules into a gas molecules into a
vacuum to describe the manner in which
money distributes itself in an economy.
Okay?
So mark's pointed to a fundamental
issue,
but he said,
well,
that's a fault with capitalism.
It's like,
no,
it isn't.
It's something way more pernicious than
that.
And it's something like,
well,
when one good thing happens to you,
it makes you a little more powerful and
attractive,
and so that fractionally increases the
possibility that another good thing will
happen to you.
And then that spirals out of control and
you get people who have,
well they have all the money or they
have all the podcast downloads.
You're in that position,
you know,
what is it?
One point 2 billion like what the hell?
But it's to those who have more and it's
not because there's something oppressive
about you,
it's because you,
you rode the wave of the prieto
distribution in it and it through your
way that way the hell up into the
stratosphere and we don't know what to
do about that.
Like should you be sharing your podcast
views with the,
with the oppressed and downtrodden?
Can you've.
Well you've got a few billion.
You could spread the damn things around.
It's not fair that you're the only one
that's being listened to.
It's the same argument and it's a
compelling argument because why the hell
should you have all that power?
If you call it power,
you could call it authority or
competence.
Isn't that a different argument because
no one's asking anyone to download
anything in specific.
No one's no one's compelling anyone to
download anything specific.
You could download whatever you want and
if you put more effort and more time and
more focus into your work,
whatever it would be,
whether it's a podcast or your youtube
videos or whatever with people enjoy it,
they gravitate towards it and then over
time it exponentially increases the
amount of people that are exposed to,
oh,
this is why I think that the.
This is the other problem with a Marxist
perspective is that and the
postmodernist in particular,
like they conflate power,
competence and authority unfairly.
Now your point,
it's sort of the point of free
marketers.
You're saying,
well look,
all I'm doing is offering a product.
I'm not compelling anyone.
It's a quality product,
or at least as far as the market is
concerned,
it is.
If it turns out that everyone wants
that,
well,
what's wrong with that?
And I'm not disagreeing with that
argument in the least,
but.
But the problem is it doesn't.
It doesn't fix the problem like the
problem with money,
let's say the problem is is that if you
let a monetary system run,
all the money ends up in the hands of a
very few,
have a very small number of people and
you're saying this is also with any sort
of creative in any creative endeavor,
man.
Now what is raw make?
I think the real issue would be to
potential
output or maximize the amount of
successful people.
You'd have to figure out what's.
Don't concentrate on what people are
doing right.
Concentrator and what people are doing
wrong.
Like what?
Why?
What are the people doing wrong that are
failing,
whether in any way.
Well that's why we put together.
Just give me one minute all that's
partly why we put together the future
authoring program because we were trying
to figure out what made people
successful and one of the things that
makes people successful is they specify
a target and then aim at it.
Right?
Because if you're all over the little,
we do know in a,
in a relatively functional society like
ours,
we know what predicts success.
Iq and conscientiousness are the biggest
predictors of success.
Now there's a genetic lottery thing
going on there that's kind of rough,
but it does say that smart people who
work hard are disproportionately likely
to succeed and then you might also say,
well,
you want to remove the impediments from
people who have those capabilities so
that they can move forward and one,
one of the predictors of success as well
is to decide what your success is going
to be and then work hard in that
direction and that actually works.
So I think that is a very useful thing
to do and that's like I said,
that's partly why we've been working in
that direction.
So.
But there's other problems that it
doesn't still still doesn't solve.
One of them is if you don't have any
money,
it's really hard to get some.
Like once you have some,
it's not so hard to get some more,
but if you're at zero,
Jesus,
man,
you're in this,
you're in the reverse situation,
you're poor,
you don't have anything.
No one wants to talk to you.
You can't get out of it because you're
too poor to get out of it.
You know you're penalized by the
economic system because you can't even
afford to start playing the game.
You're stuck at zero.
You're stuck at zero and you can't get
out,
and the revolutionary types,
you know,
they go to the people that are stuck at
zero and they say,
Hey,
you're stuck at zero.
Why don't you burn the whole goddamn
thing to the ground?
Because maybe in the next iteration you
won't be stuck at zero.
And for young men,
that's a hell of a call because they're
already,
let's call them expendable biological,
and that makes them more adventurous and
risk taking.
If someone says,
and maybe that's why they wear the
severity shirt,
it's like,
Hey,
I'm stuck at zero.
Well,
I'd rather be with the romantic who's
burning the whole thing to the ground
than to just had to stay locked in my
immobile position.
Right?
But that zero is where massive amounts
of creativity come from because of that
struggle,
massive amounts of innovation,
massive amounts of people who,
who have visions because you're not
living off of some sort of a trust fund,
you know,
you,
you have real risk and real danger and
you have a real concern about your
future.
Whereas someone who has no concerns
whatsoever and their future is carved in
stone,
they can do whatever they want and buy a
new Ferrari every year that they're not
going to have nearly the amount of
motivation as the poor person.
Yeah.
Well that may be why family fortunes
tend to only last three generations.
And you know,
you're saying,
well,
why don't you take a look at the
advantages of zero.
And one of the advantages is,
is that you're driven
by brute necessity and that can really
be motivated against.
And that's I think why,
why first?
The children are first generation
immigrants often do so well.
You know,
they're driven by necessity and it's so.
Yes.
Agreed.
However,
I would still say,
you know,
the zero issue is there are levels of
absolute privation that are so intense
that all the goodwill in the world won't
get you out of zero,
right?
If you're living in a third world
country in some very small village with
no way out whatsoever,
that is the zero of zero.
You're in Tanzania on the,
on the river,
people getting eaten by crocodiles in
your village,
you're fucked.
Zero is like a magnet.
It just holds a black hole.
Having a little very little,
maybe that motivational state actually a
generative,
right?
There's a difference,
and then what's really bizarre is those
people in that village might be happier
than the people live in a gated
community in beverly hills.
I wanted to.
I wanted to come back to your point
about about whether we should
concentrating on what you're doing right
versus what you're doing wrong.
Both of those will work and you should
actually be doing both of them
simultaneously.
You'll,
you'll maximize faster,
but the real problem is that the system
in which we concentrate on what you're
doing right,
what you're doing wrong,
and supposedly you get paid for some
integration of those things,
is that we don't,
we don't understand what we are wired to
produce evolutionarily,
right?
We think we all operate based on the
idea that we're pursuing some state of
happiness or satisfaction and,
you know,
we,
we think we know what's going to get it
for us and maybe it's inventing
something and then you'll be happy.
Uh,
but it's a trap.
The fact is,
what we are wired to do is to discover
opportunities and then when we discover
an opportunity,
it benefits the population that we come
from and we turn that discovery into
either more mouths to feed or more
consumption.
And we restore the state of privation,
right?
We restore the state in which people
don't have enough.
And so if you really wanted to fix this
problem,
if you want it to address the problems
that communism thinks it's solving,
but fails to,
you have to engineer around this,
uh,
this feature of human beings where we
pursue new opportunities and as soon as
we find a new opportunity,
instead of figuring out a way to
stabilize the benefits so that it
results in a stable sense of
satisfaction,
for example,
we fall all over ourselves to turn it
into more of the same because of course
that's how we got here.
Can you give me an example?
Which means us,
I'm sure.
So let's look at a,
something like the,
um,
let's imagine an an ancient farmer.
Ancient farmer has a piece of land and
that piece of land will support a
certain number of people with the level
of technology that the farmer is
utilizing.
Somehow the farmer ends up either
thinking of or discovering by watching
somebody else a wheel.
Now that farmer has a technology that
allows him or however many people are
working that farm to produce that much
more food with no more labor because the
wheel allows you to transport more,
for example,
at one time.
So now that same piece of land can
support more people because it can be
more efficiently farmed.
That could be stabilized as a kind of
success.
In other words,
you could turn the extra,
um,
the surplus into a kind of persistent,
a luxury,
but I mean I don't even,
luxury is a little bit too trivial sound
and you could turn it into a space where
you use that to,
uh,
to investigate important stuff or you
could turn it into more mouths to feed,
in which case as soon as you've produced
those extra mouths that are now
consuming the output of that farm.
Now the level of,
um,
you know,
fear of starvation is right back where
it was.
And so,
uh,
so,
so that's more money,
more problems.
Uh,
yeah,
essentially,
I mean,
you know,
well,
it used to be that we produced more
people now will produce a greater quest
for consumption,
but if we were smart,
what we would do is we would think about
the problem of how to take,
uh,
the gains that come from not being
bumped up at the limits of a system and
turn them into what we value,
what we collectively can.
We've done some of that.
I mean,
because,
so we've done some of that because as,
what do they say?
A rising tide lifts all ships.
And there's certainly some truth in
that.
The overall standard of living has gone
up.
So stupendously since 18,
95,
that it's an absolute miracle.
So we've,
we've done some of that.
So there's another issue.
Back to mark's.
Let's say there's another issue that we
have,
we can't contend with,
and one of those might be,
well,
imagine that in order for society to
progress,
you have to allow the individual to
compete in a relatively untrammeled
space so that they can innovate.
And then imagine that one of the
consequences of that innovation is that
you get these prieto distributions
developing because the innovator or or
the one who's second in line to the
innovator,
whatever ends up with the,
with the bulk of the spoils.
So you might say there's a cost to be
paid in inequality for innovation.
And then you could also say,
well,
too much inequality destabilizes things,
which seems to be quite quite clear.
So there's room for an intelligent
conversation about that,
right?
Because the lefties say,
oh,
too much inequality and they need to be
listened to because the evidence is
quite clear.
If you let the inequality ramp up
enough,
the whole system destabilizes because
the people at the bottom think,
fuck it,
we'll just,
we'll just flip the system upside down.
No one wants that.
Like right wing conservatives don't
that.
So because you
could make a republican argument and
say,
don't let the inequality in your
neighborhood get out of hand because the
crime rate will skyrocket.
And the empirical evidence on that is
overwhelmingly strong.
Inequality drives crime.
Now you can say,
you can argue about why,
but the fact that it does,
that's not disputable,
so we can have an intelligent discussion
between the left and the right and the
discussion would go something like this.
You need innovation,
you pay for innovation with inequality,
but you need to bind inequality because
if it's too intense,
then things destabilize.
It's like,
okay,
we can agree on that.
We've got the parameters set.
Now we have to.
Now we have to start thinking very
carefully through how to do the
redistribution issue and we don't know
how to do that.
So you might say,
well we have a guaranteed annual income
for people,
which I think is a horrible solution by
the way,
but it addresses the right problem.
The problem is is that we're hyper
productive,
but the spoils go to those at the top
and some of those resources need to be
funneled down to the people who have
zero so that they have an opportunity to
at least get to the point where they can
innovate.
And so the bloody whole bloody thing
doesn't wobble and fall.
And we could we,
and I would say in some sense that's
what the political discussion is about,
but we,
we've,
we've skittered off into these radical
oversimplifications,
which is something like,
well,
if you have more than another person,
you're an oppressor and you're evil,
and if you have less,
it's because you virtuous and victimized
and that's just a nonstarter.
So you think that there's a real problem
with something like a universal basic
income?
I think it's a horrible idea.
Well,
I think the idea that the solution is a
basic income is not a good idea because
I think the problem is deeper than that.
I don't think the fundamental problem is
that people don't have enough money.
I think the fundamental problem is that
human beings in some sense are beasts of
burden.
And if they're not given,
if they're not provided with a place
where they can accept social
responsibility,
social and individual responsibility and
an honorable manner,
they degenerate and die.
That's the opiate crisis in the West
right now.
Like men need men who are.
Men Don't need money.
They need function and we've got a
problem.
One of the problems is,
for example here,
here's an ugly stat,
I think I told you this once before,
it's illegal to induct anyone into the
armed forces if they have an Iq of less
than 83,
and the reason for that is the the armed
forces,
despite having every reason to draw the
contradictory conclusions has decided
that there isn't a single thing that you
can be trained to do in the military.
If you have an Iq of less than 83,
that isn't positively counterproductive.
That's 10 percent of the population and
we're producing a culture that's very
cognitively complex like,
what the hell are you going to do if you
can't use a computer?
Like if you can use a computer,
you're at least in the game.
If you can really use when you're hyper
powerful.
If you're not literate enough to use a
computer,
you're at 0:10
percent of the population.
The Conservatives say,
well,
there's a job for everyone.
If they just worked hard enough.
It's like a no and increasingly
know and the liberals say,
well,
everyone's basically the same and you
can train anyone to do anything.
It's like,
no,
you can't.
Yeah.
I want to go back to the inequality
point here because if you look at this
biologically,
actually I think it reveals a lot.
Why are we,
I mean,
we know from a,
from careful study that people are
motivated by the degree of inequality
more than they are the,
uh,
the absolute level of wellbeing that
they have.
And there's a very good,
it's tragic,
but a very good evolutionary reason for
this,
which is if you are working on some
piece of land and your neighbor has the
adjacent piece of land and they're doing
twice as well as you,
it's because they know something you
don't.
Right?
And so becoming focused on what they're
doing that you're not doing is a
rational thing to spend your time on so
you can figure out what it is that they
know that you don't.
In the modern environment,
this is a catastrophe because who are
your neighbors?
Well,
you've got some box sitting on the wall
of your living room that has a totally
artificial portrait of other people who
may be much wealthier than you.
And it's broadcasting in as if you're
looking in their window right in the
adjacent house,
and so you think you being triggered to,
to think that you're doing something
wrong that you might fix when in fact
the solution may not be,
first of all,
the person on the other side of that
screen may not be for real.
But even if they are,
if they're not living in the same
environment as you,
the technology is interfacing with,
uh,
with our brains badly.
But so we have the perception of massive
inequality economically,
we do have massive inequality.
You're arguing that the solution to this
involves some sort of massive
redistribution plus our solution.
But nonetheless,
redistribution is wildly unpopular for
various reasons.
And so what we've got now is a
situation.
This is speculative,
but what's really happening is that
austerity is being used as a threat to
keep people who would otherwise rebel
against the inequality in line.
And my fear about this is that this is
exactly the conditions that are going to
trigger that a tribal population against
population may ham that we were talking
about at the beginning of this
conversation,
that when people have the sense that the
the burst of growth that they were
experiencing is now over,
the natural response is to turn on those
who are not as powerful and take their
stuff,
that this is a totally indefensible,
but nonetheless biological pattern of
history and that if we want to avoid
that,
we have to stop sending the signals that
trigger us to imagine that we've just
run to the limit of the opportunity that
we had discovered and it is now time to
look and see who can't defend their
position.
How are we sending these signals?
Well,
by basically failing to provide
enough wellbeing that people's
perception of the inequality is reduced
to a tolerable level.
What's the argument for universal basic
income?
Right?
Certainly,
certainly a strong one.
And I,
you know,
it's also,
it's also a good argument for equality
of opportunity,
right?
Because people are.
People are actually not as resentful
about the success of others as you might
expect.
They're resentful about it if they feel
that the game is fixed,
but they're also willing to consider the
game long term.
So lots of people will say,
look like I'm stuck at zero,
I'm stuck at one,
but my kids might make it to four and
that's good enough.
And that's been the American dream.
Right?
And that's,
and that's a really high power antidote
to inequality.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
there's some inequality.
We need it to keep the generative
mechanism going,
but the game is fair and you can play it
too.
And there's some reasonable probability
that either you or someone you love will
be successful so that it has to be a
straight game.
And that's why ethics is so important to
keep this landscape stable.
People can't play crooked games and the
rich shouldn't be fixing the game if
they want to hold onto their money.
And the problem is,
is that some of them,
although not all,
some of them are fixing the game and no
one's happy about that and no wonder,
you know.
And,
and I guess that was evidenced to some
degree by the 2008 collapse because it
seemed and,
and I'm just as uninformed as the next
person,
so I'm,
I'm what I'm capable of commenting on
this.
It seems from the outside that the rich
disproportionately benefited from the
restabilize,
the economic system and people are not
happy about that and they shouldn't be
happy about that because it indicates
that there's something fundamentally
rotten about the game.
So you could say,
well,
maybe people can tolerate necessary
inequality if the game isn't raped.
And so that's why everybody has to act
in a manner that indicates that the game
isn't rigged and that means they can't
rake it.
That's really what it means.
So and so we're also being driven into
this inequality cornered by,
I would say by the postmodernists and
the neo Marxist because they say this is
the pernicious thing.
They say,
well,
the reason that some people have more
than others is because every hierarchy
is based on arbitrary power and they're
all oppressors.
And the reason they have the money is
because they stoled it from you.
And there's some truth in that because
there are some criminals,
but when you get to the point where you
fail to distinguish the productive
people from the criminals,
which is exactly what happened in the 19
twenties in the Soviet Union,
you better bloody well what watch out
because when you radically make things
egalitarian,
you're gonna wipe out all your
productive people and then you're going
to starve.
And so that's one of the doom and
scenarios that awaits us if this idiot
process of polarization continues and
what I find reprehensible about the
universities and you're tangled up right
up to your neck in this,
is that the universities are actively
agitating,
produce people who believe that all
inequality is due to oppression and
power.
And that's just.
Well,
first of all,
it's technically wrong,
but you guys
both operate in that system so.
Well.
Here's the problem.
No,
I.
As far as I know,
nobody has properly studied the question
of what fraction of the economy is
actually crooked.
Rent seeking,
right?
Not Productive.
And I fear that.
The answer to that question is that it's
an awful large fraction of the economy,
not because of some conspiracy,
but because opportunity is finite,
but con games aren't,
and so anybody who can find a mechanism
for transferring wealth from somebody
else for doing nothing finds that
mechanism and that thing is is ever
present.
Whereas discovering the next big thing
that's actually productive is something
that goes along and fits and starts,
and so if we were.
I mean really,
you've described it very well.
We've got a battle between two
characatures of what's true,
right are the either the market is
wonderful and it's producing great stuff
with very little corruption or
everything that makes people on equal is
the result of corruption.
Both of these things are wrong,
right?
Markets are marvelous engines for
figuring out how to do something really
well.
They're brilliant at this,
right,
and so people who see that fall in love
with it,
understandably because they're so good
at it,
but what they're terrible at is telling
you what you should want or what you
should do,
right?
If people tell markets,
here's what we would like to accomplish,
and then the markets tell us,
well,
how do we accomplish that best?
That would be a very viable system that
would not result in massive rent
seeking,
resulting in everybody feeling that all
of their misfortunes are the result of a
rigged game,
which is so massively rigged that when
they check,
they see,
yes,
that is actually large to large extent
what we're suffering from.
Um,
but they want to throw the baby out with
the bathwater.
And so they want to throw out markets
entirely,
which you know,
would be a terrible mistake.
It's,
it's a.
You asked you why,
why this has happened in the
universities and like that.
I think it's one of these runaway
positive feedback processes,
you know,
the universities start to tilt hard to
the left in the sixties and that just
went out of control.
And now we're at the point where that's
the dominant force.
And why is probably another
manifestation of one of these prieto
principals.
It was like,
well,
at some point there's enough lefties
hired so that the probability that
they're only going to hire people
equally as left or greater starts to
reach 100 percent and then you iterate
that across a couple of generations and
you get no conservatives,
which is more or less the situation say
in the humanities and most of the social
sciences and it sort of looks like a,
but it doesn't mean that anyone is
actually planning it.
Although there are conscious attempts
also to silence conservative voices,
let's say.
And then that's also driven by this
postmodern ethos.
No Neo Marxist ethos I would say that
says that all of the right,
the moral right is on the side of the
left.
You know,
and so it's the combination of those two
things.
There's more things.
I think I often think comically,
that if you paid sociology professors
three times as much,
the probability that they would be
anticapitalist would decline
precipitously.
Like I think a lot of it's driven
because there's a lot of smart people in
academia and they're underpaid relative
to their intelligence,
so in that doesn't make them happy.
So they get bitter and resentful about
that and they think,
well there's these goddamn bankers who
are hauling in $20,000,000
a year and here I am hardly struggling,
but here I am struggling comparatively
and that's the issue is comparatively on
$100,000
a year,
$120,000
a year.
You know,
I look at that and I think,
well whatever,
it doesn't matter,
but there's a,
like my colleagues are often angry with
me because I do work with the business
school,
you know,
and I also have a business,
I'm not anticapitalist in the least,
but I just dumbfounding to me because
they'll come up to me and say,
well are you so sure that you should be
working with the business school?
And I think what bloody planet are you
from two to positive question.
Like that's all businessmen are evil.
It's like,
really?
That's the level of sophistication.
That is really an argument that's been
presented to you that businessmen are
evil.
Well they don't come out and say that,
but they certainly questioned my
motivations.
For example,
in,
in informing ties with the business
school.
Like what do they say about it?
They say exactly that.
They questioned my ethics about forming
ties with the business school.
So because they don't give you any
reasons for you're supposed to it.
The reason is supposed to be self
evident Joe.
So let's give this.
I mean it's do.
I mean I,
I don't buy this argument but,
but nonetheless,
let's,
let's not,
let's not caricature.
Yes,
that's good.
In an absolutely free market,
which is not what we have,
but we have something that tends in that
direction in an absolutely free market.
If you compete to individuals,
one of whom is completely amoral,
will embrace any opportunity.
If it makes a profit no matter what it
is,
and the other individual has some limit
to what they will do.
Well then there's no question.
Who Wins?
If we give this experiment a long enough
period,
the individual who will do anything will
outcompete the individual with moral
limits because depending on what the
game is though,
because people find out that you have no
moral limits,
then they're going to remove themselves
from your market.
Unfortunately not.
And here's the.
I know it seems like that and in,
in,
in any given round,
that's true,
but to the extent that what you're
saying is to the extent that people
police,
um,
their purchasing and they will,
you know,
they will stop using uber.
If Uber is ethically compromised,
for example,
um,
well then the point is,
well,
what's the game?
The game is to figure out which things
are being monitored and not do any of
the unethical things that are being
monitored,
but to do all of the unethical things
that aren't being monitored.
And so the individual who is perceiving
which things they can get away with has
an advantage and a psychopath advantage.
Well,
I don't even want to call it the
psychopath advantage,
right?
What this is,
is that a market will train you to do
this if it is unregulated and the best
that the ethical that the ethically I'm
restrained person can do is compete dead
even they have no way of getting ahead
because the person that is completely
free,
the amoral business actor has the
ability to do anything that the
constrained actor has just depend
entirely upon what the battlefield is
not really.
There's sort of one exception and that
exception is people who have done
something,
uh,
that has suddenly put them in a powerful
position,
right?
So,
um,
I don't whack people tech people who
have skyrocketed as a result of having
innovated the next big thing have not
been through the markets,
training them to discover the,
the landscape of what isn't being
monitored,
that you can make a profit.
That's one of the fascinating things
about tech people in general,
is that these gigantic tech corporations
almost all leaned left.
Well,
the gigantic tech corporations lean
left.
That's true.
On the other hand,
I mean,
I hate to say it,
but think about how Google started,
right?
Don't,
don't be evil,
right?
I think they actually meant that,
right,
and the thing is don't be evil is what
it sounds like when you haven't been
trained by the market to have,
to do whatever you have to do to beat
your competition.
You've just come up with the great
search engine and suddenly you're on top
of the world.
Um,
but over time what happens,
that entity is now exposed to
competition from a bunch of other
entities that increasingly will find an
advantage in being freer to do ethically
questionable stuff.
And so what it does is it forces an
entity like google to evolve in the
direction of a morality.
So now don't be evil with China and
Google just to expand into China.
And so,
you know,
they had to make a deal with the devil,
so to speak.
Right?
And they will have to accept censorship.
They will find ways to rationalize
everything because to not rationalize
that which their competitors can avail
themselves of would be to perish.
And so the issues was a,
there was all sorts of fake google going
on,
just like they have fake apple stores in
China.
They don't have the same sort of
copyright laws that we have and you can
essentially plagiarize anything you want
on Brett,
you.
You also said that I shouldn't make a
straw man of the antibusiness argument
of my peers and there's another way that
I shouldn't make a straw man of it.
Like despite the fact that I'm not
anticapitalist.
I don't believe that every entity is
a business either and one of the things
that has happened to universities that
has actually been pathologized in a
number of dimensions,
but they've also pathologize along the
business dimension as the administrators
have become increasingly trained or
drawn from the ranks of business
managers.
Because the university is actually not a
business.
It's a like a church isn't a business.
There are organizations that aren't
businesses that you can't just cram into
the free market structure Willy Nilly
and so my colleagues also object to the,
to the transformation of the university,
into a business entity,
run by profit seeking Mbas,
and they should object to that because
that's not what the institution is for.
So there are reasons for them to be
skeptical.
Say of my association with the business
school that aren't merely a reflection
of a simplistic anticapitalist etiology.
Oh,
there are lots of,
there are lots of
things that are not,
have no immunity to contact with the
market.
Right?
What has happened to the university
system is that markets have pushed it in
all kinds of directions that are not
healthy for the mission of the academy.
Um,
and this is also true,
you know,
journalism is well done in a market,
either write journalism done in the
market,
ends up telling you what you want to
hear,
not what you need to know.
Um,
so anyway,
markets are wonderful,
but there are certain things they
shouldn't be allowed to touch and there
are certain things that they shouldn't
do,
like tell us what to want right?
There not,
there's no magic principle by which a
market knows what's healthy and what,
you know,
you might
didn't have.
That also then brings us back to another
part of the conservative liberal left
dilemma,
which is,
well,
you know,
to direct the market means to impose the
heavy hand of the state and its
potential pathologies on the market.
But to leave it alone completely means
that it wanders randomly through a,
through an indeterminant landscape.
And I guess part of the issue there too
is it's sort of like,
well how do we,
how do we,
how do we properly balance for foresight
and planning,
which you'd think would have some role
in,
in the construction of large scale
states.
It's like,
well,
what do we want the landscape to look
like?
How do we balance that with the sort of
comprehensive computations that the
market allows?
And of course the answer to that is we
have political discussions about it all
the time that are untrammeled so that we
can adjust the ratio between those two
things as necessary.
So again,
that's a,
that's a argument on the side of free
speech.
I mean really it could,
couldn't be
more important.
The real answer is that both failures
are frightening,
right?
You really don't want a state,
a nannying you and overregulating the
market and taking the magic out of it
and you don't want the completely
unregulated landscape where the market
starts probing the minds of your
children and figuring out how to sell
them,
things that they don't have any ability
to resist,
right?
You need to figure out what that path is
and it's not,
but
you can't do it in a landscape where you
can't talk about the questions and this
brings us to censorship,
doesn't it?
Because this is a real issue with the
marketplace of free ideas.
When you're talking about whether it's
Google or youtube or whoever might be
imposing their own morality and their
own ideas on what you should and should
not be able to discuss and what should
and should not be monetized.
You're.
You're essentially imposing these
limits.
These look,
I've read once and it's a very good
point that freedom breeds inequality
because you're free to put as much
effort as you'd like into something and
you're going to get an equal results and
that if you are truly free in a free
world,
some people are going to do far better
than others and just based on their own
input,
just based on their effort,
just based on the.
The amount of focus and dedication they
have.
It is very unequal.
You know,
I,
I know many people that are far more
dedicated than other people that I know
and they do better.
Yeah,
well that's,
that's well buttressed by the empirical
literature because while I mentioned
earlier that the two best predictors of
longterm success or intelligence and
conscientiousness and what intelligence
is probably something like the number
of,
of credible operations that you can
manifest in a given period of time.
It's something like speed now.
It's not only that but it speed's a big
part of it.
So if what you're doing is working and
you can do it faster,
that works better.
Okay.
That's pretty damn straightforward.
And the next thing is,
well,
conscientiousness,
conscientiousness would be something
like how many of those cycles of effort
are devoted to that specific task and it
turns out that if there's a relationship
between the effort and task success,
more effort is better,
but and so I can give you some
indication of the power of that.
So if you have good measures of
conscientiousness in Icu,
you can predict someone's success in a
competitive landscape with a correlation
of about point six.
And what that would mean is imagine that
you tried to pick people,
you just said randomly,
you're going to be a success in the top
half of the successful people say.
And you're going to be in the bottom
half.
You'd have a 50,
50,
50 percent chance of,
of,
of making that selection correctly.
If you did it randomly,
if you did it informed by the results of
a good cognitive test and a
conscientious test,
you'd be right 85 percent of the time.
So you could say with 85 percent
accurately accuracy,
which of two people would be more likely
to be in the top 50 percent.
So it's a whopping effect and it's
actually some validation for the
essential integrity of our system
because we hope given that it's
essentially an open meritocracy that
smarter,
hardworking people would do better and
they do.
Now.
Other factors apply.
Corruption,
for example,
lots of factors apply.
I mean,
for one thing wrapped up in ICU is a big
question,
which is how much of the differences in
Iq that exist is democratized bubble.
That is to say how much of this is the
result of environments that aren't
enriching or there's lead the water or
who knows what vitamins,
right?
My,
my sense actually my intuition based on
what I know biologically is that a huge
fraction,
maybe all of it,
but a huge fraction of differences in Iq
is actually,
um,
could be generalized and that's part of
equal opportunity.
It's not an equal opportunity to see
some mistake about that.
And that's partly because,
I mean maybe because I spent a lot of,
because I'm interested in the
amelioration of differences,
you know,
so for example,
that's why I built this future authoring
program.
It's like,
Hey,
if we can figure out how to make people
more effective,
well let's do it.
So I scoured the literature on,
on Iq enhancement and it's bloody
dismal,
man.
It's rough.
It's very,
very difficult to put together a
cognitive training program.
Like some things have worked in a major
way.
Like the fact that people aren't
starving,
has wiped out,
has moved the bottom of the ICU
distribution way up over the last
hundred years.
That's been like a walloping success.
But a lot of the things that we hope
would work like headstart's a good
example of that,
you know,
headstart was part of the American war
on poverty and the idea was you'd give,
you know,
deprived,
deprived kids lay up early before they
hit school and start training them
cognitively earlier.
And the hope was that you'd get a prieto
thing going where they'd be a little
smarter in kindergarten and then they do
a little better in grade one and that
would make them do even more better in
grade two.
More better,
do better in grade two.
But what happened,
what happened was that the kids who went
through headstart actually did get a
cognitive jump on their competitors,
but all the other kids caught up by
grade six and by grade six,
there was absolutely no effect
whatsoever of the training program left.
Now,
headstart did have a couple of benefits.
One was fewer teenage pregnancies and
fewer dropouts,
but that was probably because the kids
who got into headstart were either
socialize better or that some fraction
of them were removed from for some time
from extremely toxic environments just.
Well,
they happen to be at headstart,
but it didn't produce the cognitive
improvements that everyone right and
left were equally hoping for.
Yeah.
But this is,
this is in some sense a,
it's a very much an uncontrolled
experiment,
right?
Because a headstart starts late.
Yep.
And B,
it doesn't insulate you from all of the
stuff that comes along with.
Oh yeah,
growing up in,
in the deprived neighborhood.
And so,
absolutely.
And now also,
I don't know what the truth is of,
um,
of Human Iq.
And there there are some results that
suggest some things that are not
hopeful.
On the other hand,
some of them just simply run a foul with
the biological realities of intelligent.
Well here,
here's a good example of of the,
of the lack of malleability.
I mean there's a couple of things.
The first is that we may have already,
we may already be at a point of
diminishing returns in terms of
eliminating
individual differences in Iq because
everyone has central heating,
everyone has air conditioning,
everyone has enough food,
everyone has access to the.
An infinite pool of information.
So you can say even if you're in a
deprived environment,
but you're smart,
the intellectual landscape is wide open
to you.
Now.
I'm not saying that's the case,
but you can make a case for that.
But the more dismal end of the,
of the biological research on Iq shows
things like if you take identical twins
at birth and you put them in a adopted
out families that the Iq of the adopted
out twins as much there,
much closer to the original biological
parents than to the adoptive parents and
be almost perfectly correlated with one
another.
And that correlation increases as the
separated twins' age.
So let's say you had a twin,
you were both adopted out at birth.
We test your Iq is at four.
They're fairly close.
They're closer to your biological
parents than your adoptive parents.
But then we test you every year until
you're 60.
By the time you're 60.
No matter how long you've been separated
as,
uh,
an identical twin,
your Iq score is so much like your twins
Iq score that it's as if the same person
was being tested twice.
And that's a really complicated one
because you think,
well,
as twins traveled through the
environment and accrue different
experiences,
their ICU should diverge.
Like obviously that's not what happens.
They converge.
So there,
there are a lot of places to critique
that.
For one thing,
there aren't very many identical twins
raised apart.
It's a small sample.
This is definitely true.
Those identical twins raised apart carry
with them whatever effects there were
from before they were born,
for sure and the same.
And so if,
if they,
if they've been damaged by an
environment that was unhealthy for their
mother when she was pregnant,
than they would carry that through and
it would show up as a,
as a similar Iq later in life.
So that one really wants to see that
this is true on the positive side,
not just the negative side.
So anyway,
there's,
I'm not saying that there's nothing to
it.
I'm really saying I think we don't know.
It's very early in this,
but what I can say,
and I think a couple of the things that
we've settled on in this conversation
already are that a,
uh,
an environment in which we can say
anything that we can advance any
argument and tested.
It doesn't mean that that argument is
protected,
but that any argument can be advanced
and then challenged that that is
inherent to navigating.
And the other thing that I think we
would agree on is that equality of
opportunity is nothing but good,
right?
A fair game with equality of
opportunity,
fair game with equality of opportunity.
And I guess one thing I would add,
I don't know if we would agree on this,
but um,
you were talking about the fact that,
uh,
I forget which thing exactly but,
but that a system based on merit
produces inequality because people will
freedom that freedom produces
inequality.
That's not necessarily a bad thing,
but it doesn't mean that we are
obligated to,
to
ride it all the way down.
Right?
The fact is we could make people safe to
fail,
right?
So that you are encouraged to attempt to
do something highly valuable.
And if you,
if it doesn't work out,
then the point is you're not homeless.
This would be the argument for something
like universal basic income that your
needs are taken care of,
your food,
your shelter,
and now you're free to pursue any ideas
that you might have that you would
ordinarily be saddled down by your,
your issues with food.
And there is some evidence of that.
Actually happening in Canada now,
these are multi variable problems and so
I'm not claiming that this is true,
but it's suggestive.
The rate of entrepreneurial activity in
Canada is actually higher than in the
United States and one reason for that
appears to be the fact that if you're
25,
27,
let's say,
and you have a family,
you can quit your job and start a
startup and you don't lose your
healthcare.
Right?
And so now you know,
the issue of universal health core is
obviously a very thorny one and it's not
like the Canadian system works
perfectly,
but it doesn't work too badly and we've
been able to manage it for about 50
years.
You know,
we have,
there's,
there's artificial scarcity in the
system and the delay times are longer
than they would be if you flew to the
Mayo Clinic and bought your healthcare.
Like I would say that at the high end
the American healthcare system is better
than the Canadian healthcare system,
but I would say at the middle and at the
low end,
the Canadian healthcare system is
clearly preferable and it's also
cheaper.
Which is quite interesting because you
would expect,
especially if you're a free market type
that,
you know,
I know the healthcare system in the US
is not precisely free market,
but it is more so than it is in Canada,
yet Americans pay a substantially higher
proportion of their overall devote,
a higher proportion of their overall GDP
to personal healthcare that Canadians
do.
And,
and the stats are similar.
If you look at other,
you know,
socialized medical medical assist,
a great piece on that by Adam Ruins
everything.
Have you ever seen that television show?
It's really interesting.
The breaks down pretty much,
uh,
a lot of different subjects,
but big breaks down the American
healthcare system to pretty much where
it went wrong.
And I just encourage anybody to go watch
it because it just shows how the
elevated the price of all sorts of
different things to try to make up for a
lack of profits.
And it's really fascinating little
piece.
Um,
we are already almost three hours into
this,
so we haven't talked about Hitler.
Oh my God.
Well we kind of,
we kind of did kind of have.
But let me just,
uh,
do you want to lay out your argument
about Hitler and that I'll respond to it
and uh,
um,
I don't know if I do want to.
I mean,
I think I,
I actually think that I should stop
because I'm kind of at the limits of I'm
at the point where the probability that
I will say something stupid is starting
to increase and I would
rather not because just saying the
things that I'm trying to say that
aren't stupid is dangerous enough.
This isn't the topic where you want to
make that kind of.
Yes.
I would say maybe is there a more
charged subject?
It's funny that it's charged because as
you point out,
we're pretty much all in agreement about
it,
right?
I mean,
you find someone who's not in there
instantly ostracized from society.
I mean anybody who has an argument about
gingiss con.
I mean,
there's a really fascinating take on
this by Dan Carlin from hardcore history
where he's talking about the amount of
time that has passed since a horrible
atrocity and that there are people that
will argue that gang is Khan who killed
10 percent of the world's population,
changed things so badly that it
literally lower the carbon footprint of
the human race while he was alive,
killed some untold number of millions of
people and was responsible for their
deaths.
People look to him and they find all
sorts of positive things to attribute to
his reign,
opening up trade with China,
opening up trade routes,
although all these different things that
people have attributed to him and that
some day someone may do the same thing
about Adolf Hitler right now.
Well,
it's impossible.
He,
uh,
he certainly made that job very
difficult with all of the documentation,
especially the films.
But,
um,
but let's just say the argument that I
want to love,
I want to be really careful to do this
so that it can't be misinterpreted by
anybody.
I'm going to enjoy watching this.
Okay?
If I'm cornered,
will,
you know a man going out?
Okay.
So my argument for all
those years ago in my paper that I was
dead for Bob triggers that I mentioned
at the beginning was that Hitler was a
monster as we all know,
but he was a rational monster.
That the program that he deployed was
not what he said.
What he said was wrong in many places,
especially where it gets near Darwinism.
It's just all tangled and broken.
But what he did was a rational from the
point of view of increasing the amount
of resource that was dedicated to
producing members of his population.
And so my point is this is the danger
that we are in.
If we allow ourselves to imagine that
genocidal impulses are more or less gone
from the world because we've all assumed
where we've all agreed that they're a
bad thing.
And the point is that they exist in a,
in a latent program,
and at a point when you have austerity
as a result of a,
usually a,
uh,
an opportunity that has run its course
and has resulted in the population
growing to fill that opportunity.
And suddenly
there's nowhere to go because the
opportunity is all been absorbed.
The tendency of people is to figure out
who,
what other population is weak,
and if that population is across a
border,
then there's some excuse for war and if
the population is within the border,
then it's a genocide.
But the point is that is an ever present
danger for us to clear it.
Clarify one thing,
because this argument was sort of
phrased as we have a disagreement about
Hitler and I would like to point out
that I don't actually disagree with
anything that you just said because if I
remain relatively silent,
I don't want to be seen.
I don't want it to be seen that the fact
that I'm disagreeing with you means or
that there is a disagreement means that
it's a disagreement about any of that.
I think the disagreement was something
like I said,
that Hitler was even more evil than we
thought he was.
And I think,
correct me if I'm wrong,
you're pointing out the danger of
assuming that you can put Hitler in a.
He was just a monster box and don't
think about it anymore.
And I would say I agree absolutely with
that.
I mean,
I've studied Hitler a lot and there's a
bunch of things that you can't say about
him.
You can't say he was stupid.
You can't say he was without artistic
talent.
You can't say that he was a poor
organizer.
You can't say that he wasn't
charismatic.
You can't say that he did wonders for
equal Germany's economy and the first
part of his reign and,
and,
and so it's very necessary when you're,
if you're dealing intelligently with a
true monster that you give the devil his
due.
Yeah.
Uh,
so I think the thing that I saw in your
video was your argument was that as he
was losing,
instead of putting the genocide on pause
and winning and winning,
the warning that he,
he ratcheted it up the Janet.
I don't know if it would really be.
I don't think it's necessarily fair to
say that it was him that did that,
although I think he had a hand in it.
It does appear to me that that's what
happened.
Right.
And My,
my point would simply be,
and again,
there I couldn't possibly be less
sympathetic with the individual.
My point is simply that from an
evolutionary point of view,
if your objective is coldly to increase
the number of genomes that are spelled
the same way that yours are on earth,
that a,
he did enslave those Jews who were most
fit to work in service of the German war
machine.
Right?
That's what those camps are.
Not all of the camps were work camps.
But Auschwitz for example,
was both a work camp and a death camp.
And so there was this a tendency to
enslave.
And so let me ask you a question about
this because you know,
I think you have to make a pretty
tenuous biological argument to say that
there's evolutionary utility in
increasing the number of your kinsmen,
but unless they're very close,
but,
but here's a slight variation of that.
You tell me what
you think about this.
Is it reasonable to presume that a
decent survival strategy is to
homogenize your environment with regards
to under some conditions to homogenize
your,
your environment with regards to racial
or ethnic differences?
To decrease the probability that you and
yours are going to be killed.
Oh yeah.
Again,
no this.
Yes,
you are right.
That the extent that there's another
population that's distinct,
that that population,
even if it is small and has little power
now might not be small and have little
power later and so undoubtedly that
program is there too.
But I would say that the tendency to
believe that evolution only functions at
the level of kin when you're talking
about very close relatives,
I believe is an error that the result of
the fact that evolutionists early on
wished to operationalize fitness and
it's very hard to operationalize fitness
across population level differences.
And so they built a definition that is
about immediate kin,
but there's no logical reason to imagine
that that peters out at the edge.
So and so.
So you're okay.
So all I'm arguing is that what Hitler
did was go after a population inside his
border that was more distantly related
to the people who were his constituents.
And then he went obviously after Eastern
Europe and sought the future of Germany
in Russia and it took $12 million,
a russianist of turnaround,
the German war machine.
I mean,
those are military deaths that were
investing more civilian deaths.
But um,
but the point is he did not succeed in
doing what he set out to do,
but he also didn't fail in the sense
that he took a bunch of resources that
belong to a population that was more
distantly related.
And,
um,
he got rid of those people and by
getting rid of them,
increased the amount of resource that
was available to ariens.
This has nothing to do.
Jeans are not interested in figuring out
which genes are superior.
All of the language about German
superiorities nonsense.
However,
genes are very interested.
I mean,
they're obviously jeans,
they don't think,
but they act as if they are interested
in replacing alternative spellings.
Part of the reason that you're walking
through this just so that this track of
this remains self-evident is to caution
people against,
to alert people to the fact that the
sorts of programs that Hitler both ran
and elicited from people are lurking in
our,
let's say,
in our genome,
in our,
in our set of biological possibilities,
and we have to be very awake to that
fact on an ongoing basis.
They are lurking in our genomes,
which does not mean that we as adults
have this as a possibility.
Many people will not go with this.
Other people have it lurking to be
triggered.
And I think what worries me is that
trump,
I think very cynically utilized this
lurking program in order to gain office
that he played upon the fact that
certain people were waiting to hear
those noises and what he said about
Charlottesville,
you know,
again,
he did not,
uh,
he did not go after the
nationalists.
The way that you see the white
nationalist response,
do you see,
knows the dealer storm had?
Is that what it's called?
I think one of the,
one of the white nationalist papers had
a breakdown of what trump did and that
essentially at the end they were saying
he didn't go after us.
He didn't target us.
This is very good.
He was very clear that it was all sides
and that he'd never wants.
Targeted us.
Didn't say anything bad about us.
And they said God blessed trump.
At the end of it.
There's a real tricky issue there about
truth,
you know,
because I was.
Because my free speech free speech panel
that I was a part of was counseled.
I had to make comments in the Canadian
media about Charlottesville.
And so I really had to think about what
trump said because the,
the fact that there is reprehensible
behavior on both sides of the extremes
of the distribution is true.
However,
truth is a tricky thing because you have
to take the temporal context into
account,
you know,
because I would say you can imagine that
there are white lies and black truths.
Uh,
black truth is when you use the truth in
a way that isn't truthful,
just like a white lie is when you use a,
when you lie in a way that isn't
harmful,
you can use the truth to wound and hurt,
and what that really means is that
you've misused the truth and so it's
actually a complex form of lie.
But what,
what,
what trump did wrong.
This is independent of whether or not he
was actually engaging in manipulation or
deceit,
was he failed to specify the time and
the place for the utterance because what
he should have come out and done with
said,
I unequivocally denounce the white
supremacist racism that emerged in
Charlottesville.
And then he should have shut up and then
two weeks later he could've said,
well,
would we look at the political landscape
as a whole?
Perhaps commenting on Berkeley.
He could have said it's pretty obvious
that there are reprehensible individuals
acting out at both ends of the extreme.
But the Charlottesville week wasn't the
week to make that point.
So.
And you know why he did that.
While it could be just ineptness because
it was a very tricky week to exactly get
things right.
I don't think so.
I think actually we can look at the,
uh,
what he did during the election and I
think we should expect that he would do
exactly what he did.
Well,
fair enough.
That I think there's,
there's a wink and a nod to them.
Always would it?
Neo Nazis and once President Donald
Trump's response with dale.
Yeah.
See,
see if he could see the actual.
Does it show the actual text of what
they wrote?
Because
quote from the editor here,
right there,
uh,
increased even mentioned anything to do
with us.
Reporters were screaming at him in the
white nationalism when he just walked
out of the room.
Huh?
Right.
Um,
there was,
there was an actual article that they
wrote on one of those websites.
Trump's comments were good.
He didn't attack.
That's it.
You didn't attack us.
Just that the nation should come
together.
Nothing specific against us.
He said that we need to study why people
get so angry and implied there was
hate.dot
on both sides.
Exclamation point.
So he implied that the Antifa are
haters,
I mean,
so that,
that energize them in a way,
and I mean there's no secret that they
support him,
you know.
Um,
my friend Alonzo Boden is a very funny
quote.
He's a comedian.
He goes,
not all trump supporters are racist,
but all racists are trump supporters.
Right?
It's a great quote.
And he,
that's,
there's political power in that,
whether or not trump is a racist or
whether it's the wink and the nod to
that side,
that is the only wink and a nod that
they're getting.
Yeah.
Or even,
or even insufficient denunciation,
which was kind of what did in,
there's a Canadian journalist named
faith,
Goldie who got fired from rebel media
for being,
being a,
uh,
being accused of being too cozy with the
daily stormer type.
She did a podcast with,
with crypto.
And I listened to the podcast.
We're carefully.
She was actually one of the people that
were supposed to be a panelist on this
free speech talk.
And so that put us in a real bind.
But well,
what happened in the podcast?
Well,
what happened was,
in my estimation was that she didn't
properly fulfill her role as critical
journalist.
She was.
It was sort of like a discussion with
your friendly neighborhood,
Neo Nazi,
and what I mean by that is she didn't
ally herself,
La Ellie,
hers,
ally herself with any of the purported
aims of the Neo Nazi people she was
talking to,
but I think she failed to criticize them
sufficiently.
She didn't ask the tough questions,
you know now,
and that end that that was a.
That was while it was a fatal error.
I mean she got fired from rebel media
and it's going to have terrible
repercussions for her,
although she may land on her feet on
rebel media is very conservative as
well.
Certainly by Canadian standards.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
No,
rebel media like imploded in the
aftermath of Charlottesville because of
what faith goal he did with,
with a,
a daily.
It wasn't even the daily stormer was a
group called Crypto,
but there,
there are associated with the daily
stormer,
so she went on there,
which I think you could make.
You could make a case that that's okay
as a journalist you can go talk to Neil
Nazis,
but the question is how do you talk to
them and write the answer to that is you
point out their agenda.
You don't allow them to masquerade as
friendly,
as friendly,
innocent people.
You can't do that.
And so I would say she,
she damned herself by
efficiently criticizing the villains.
It was something like that.
You familiar?
I'm sure you are familiar with Louis
Theroux?
No,
I'm not really through the documentary
and genome from England.
Fascinating guy.
Fantastic.
Like one of the best and one of the
things that he's done is um,
well he's,
he's interviewed a ton of different
people,
but one of the great ones that he did
was the Westboro Baptist church.
And he sort of embedded himself with
them and was a very congenial and very
kind and unthreatening and stayed with
them for long periods of time,
like weeks on end and got them to
eventually like expose who they were and
and understand from like the point of
view of an insider and in a sense
without necessarily condemning them,
but with just constantly asking
questions,
but being very,
very polite about it.
Not like a bunch,
not,
not like a lot of serious,
like a confrontational criticism rather.
But a very friendly sort of polite
British way of discussing things.
And he's particularly good at embedding
himself.
He did it with scientology.
He's done it with a bunch of different
groups.
He embeds himself
just sorta.
So there's.
So there's a justification for
attempting that sort of thing.
Clearly this.
But,
and I really had to think this through
because well what happened with our talk
was it was so hall of mirrors,
like it was like it was a talk about
free speech talks being shut down on
campus.
That was shut down by a campus and it
was a panel of people who purport to
support free speech,
who knocked someone off the panel
because of something.
Well,
not precisely that she said,
but it's close enough to make the irony
rather palpable is so I had to go
through what happened with faith very
carefully to figure out what the right
ethical pathway was,
you know,
but I listened to the podcast very
carefully.
I listened to it with my son and we
talked about it a lot and our conclusion
was that she had failed to.
She had failed to.
She didn't ask enough tough questions.
One would have done it,
even.
Maybe two would have done it for sure,
but it was the discussion was to corteal
mm.
And it could've even been cordial to
your point because maybe that would have
led to more discussions,
but it should have been cordial with one
snake bite.
No,
that was required to make that snake
bite.
I mean,
well,
it depends on what you mean by required.
Well,
my thought is to find out what these
people really want and really like.
We're really trying to achieve.
Sometimes you don't have to be
confrontational with them.
You just got to allow them to be
comfortable and come out.
Bell did that really great on a CNN show
with the KKK.
He sort of just allowed them to be
themselves and they became more and more
comfortable with him.
The more time they spend with them to
the point where they're actually joking
around with him,
but you got to see the ugliness was so
obvious and evident and without him
confronting them on without him yelling
and arguing,
you got to see it from him.
Just being friendly and joking around
with them.
Now nobody would ever accuse a black man
like come out bell with being a
sympathizer with the KKK.
He was in this inarguable position like
no one,
no one could get accused him of it.
This woman I'm assuming is white.
That's where the problem lies.
One of the problems,
but she was a black woman in the very
same situation like oprah was in the
past.
Like Oprah interviewed the KKK in the
past and she was never accused of being
like somehow or another,
a sympathetic person to them.
Right.
And somehow we have to raise the
threshold of a fence.
There's,
there are lots of ways to contribute to
the conversation.
One of them may be to embed yourself and
actually allow the world to see people
who are doing something abhorrent in
the,
in the way that they see themselves so
you can understand it.
Just being there asking questions.
You don't necessarily have to be like,
what are you going to change them?
And being critical to them.
Just getting in arguments with them.
I mean they might be able to see
something from that from their response
to like rational discussion about their
issues.
This brings us down a whole other rabbit
hole which maybe we could talk about at
some point in the future because this is
a really interesting topic.
You know,
like part of the reason that I've been
accused of being on the far right say or
on the right is because I've talked to
people talk with people who perhaps
have,
are closer.
What would you say have an association
network that might be more closely
aligned with that than people are
comfortable with,
but my attitude is being too.
It's,
and I don't want to talk about this in
much detail because it's really
complicated,
but the the,
the anti left spectrum,
let's say is very confused and it could
easily tilt very rapidly into the hard
right Auntie left,
which is the danger that,
that you were describing and partly what
I'm hoping is that I can talk to people
who might conceivably beyond that
developmental pathway because they're
tired of being accused of implicit
racism,
let's say and say,
look,
you can be anti radical left without
falling all the way into the to the far
right and here's how you might do it,
but that means I have to talk to them
and then if I talk to them,
that means I risk association with them.
In that risks being tainted.
It's a very tricky line to walk,
but it's also one of the.
One of the
big problems with this hard stance of
the,
of the left of the hard left.
Like this pepe,
the frog thing like that,
anybody.
I mean,
one of the things that I tweeted with
some guy that called me and you just
admitted you're a Nazi because you.
I posted a meme that someone had created
of me as pepe the frog and apparently
there's pepe the frog of everybody and
so I put this guy was like,
well,
you just admitted you're a Nazi.
And I'm like,
see,
this is a part of the problem and this
creates a massive blow back.
People are getting angry because that
frog for the most part is used
humorously and yeah,
actually you used the phrase defensive
humor and it really is,
and I think,
I mean this is.
I didn't mean to interrupt your job,
but don't please do.
There's something about the idea that
the effectiveness of this meme is that
it tangles people with no sense of humor
in knots and that's a huge part of why
those things are generated.
That's exactly right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm fearing that I'm saying something
about this frog and that there's going
to be something that's going to emerge
that I should know about that somehow
I'm admitting something,
but all I'm saying is what I see is a
lot of people using it to taunt people.
Yes.
Can't figure out.
I think that's the vast majority of it.
I do believe that.
And I think the same thing about the
kick of standard
is that that's almost all humor.
Yeah.
And there's some massive problem with
pushing back against that and calling
those people Nazis and racists and
especially when they're just using humor
and especially when it's very clear,
if you look at all the memes online and
I went thoroughly through Google to find
them.
There is some,
uh,
born once.
There are some horrible ones.
There are some ones that are with the
Nazi uniforms.
There's some,
there's some anti jus ones.
There's some horrific ones.
Most of them are not that.
Most of them,
the vast majority of them are humorous.
And if the.
And again,
these people are not coordinating,
so if one person decides to make a
Mickey Mouse Racist Meme,
which by the way a lot of the earliest
mickey mouse cartoons,
you could just take a screenshot and
they're fucking tremendously racist
because dealing with the side of the
times,
I mean images of black people that were
extremely cartoonish,
you know,
giant lips,
black faces the whole deal.
Horribly racist.
You could say Mickey Mouse is fucking
racist,
don't go to Disneyland.
No one saying that.
Right?
But they could.
And this is a slippery slope.
You start with the frog,
you know,
and you know,
first they came for pepe and I didn't
say anything.
Yeah,
well if the frog is racist,
you start wondering what isn't racist
because it's bloody cartoon frog.
But you can make a cartoon about
everything that has ever existed and
make that racist.
It doesn't mean that the frog is racist.
This is where it's crazy.
It's like what percentage of people are
making the frog races?
And then for the southern poverty law
center to say that this is a symbol of
hate.
Now this frog.
Well,
well guess what,
you just back these fucking people up
against the wall and you shared their
offense is because now they're
realizing,
oh well these people are mad.
They're not just mad like angry,
but mad like insane.
Like you're not looking at this thing
rationally at all.
You're saying that a frog where 99
percent of the memes or just humorous or
silly.
Now the frog is a hate symbol.
Not only a hate symbol,
but Nazi white supremacist.
I mean the.
You're just drawing up all of the space
between their preposterous perspective
and the nightmare at the other end of
the spectrum.
And the point is almost all of us live
in that intermediate space.
It's almost all thoughts live in that
intermediate space.
There's a variability of all thoughts,
you know,
and there's,
there's flexibility of all ideas and
when you're talking about something that
we're extremely humorous,
you're talking about a humorous frog.
I mean God damn to crawl that all hate
when sometimes it's hate and by who,
by whatever the fucking people are that
did that hateful thing.
Those are the people that are hateful,
not the other ones that are using that
frog for humor.
I mean,
this is the fact that this is a.
An argument at all.
Just shows how lost we are in these
ideological arguments is left versus
right.
Extreme end of the spectrum on one end
of the field throwing rocks at the far
end of the field.
Most of us are in the middle somewhere.
It's hopeless.
If we,
if we cannot have discussions about a
frog cartoon,
cartoon frog.
I mean Jesus Christ.
Well,
that's so weird.
It's a nice conclusion.
Yeah,
it might be.
It might be.
Listen,
this was a lot of fun.
It was always this and I'm glad you guys
came up with this idea and I'm glad we
had the time to do it.
It was fantastic to meet you.
I'm Jordan Peterson.
What is your twitter handle again?
Jordan Peterson and Bret Weinstein.
Weinstein on twitter.
Weinstein saying Weinstein.
It doesn't make.
You're not changeable.
Sorry.
SORTA,
sorta.
Alright,
but thank you guys.
Really appreciate it.
A lot of fun.
Yep.
Good to see you again.
Bye.
Everybody.